ASSEMBLY AND NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING A FEW
REMINDERS MASKS ARE NOT REQUIRED
BUT ARE ENCOURAGED WHILE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND OTHER COMMON
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL.
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON AND BY PHONE THE NUMBER
FOR PHONE TESTIMONY IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. THIS NUMBER IS ALSO
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND ALSO APPEARS ON THE
VIDEO FEED. ONCE THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY. WE HAVE
EIGHTEEN MEASURES ON THE AGENDA
TODAY WITH FOUR OF THEM PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT. ITEM SEVEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ITEM EIGHT
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ITEM NINE
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO AND ITEM
TWELVE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
ARE OWNED THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
WE'RE READY TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED OUR FIRST BILL IS AB
SIXTEEN ELEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
START WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN. I FIRST WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
RECENT AMENDMENT SPECIFICALLY
PAGE BROKAW. UNDER CURRENT LAW
WHEN THERE'S A THREAT OF LEAKAGE
OF OIL COMING FROM A VESSEL THAT
VESSEL MUST IMMEDIATELY REPORT
THAT DISCHARGE CAL OH YES
SHOCKINGLY HOWEVER IF A VESSEL
WERE TO BE CALLED THE BECAUSE OF
THE OIL LEAKAGE SUCH AS HITTING
A PIPELINE WITH ITS ANCHOR LIKE
WE WITNESSED AN ORANGE COUNTY
LAST OCTOBER. THERE IS NO LAW
MANDATING THEY MUST NOTIFY
ANYONE AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO MERELY PUT
INTO PLACE PROTOCOLS FOR A
VESSEL OPERATOR TO NOTIFY CAL OH
YES ABOUT A STRIKER POTENTIAL
STRIKE OF A SUBMERGED PIPELINE
THE BILL WOULD ALSO INSTRUCT THE
OFFICE TO NOTIFY THE PIPELINE
OPERATORS SO THEY MADE BEGIN
REPAIRS ON THE PIPELINE.
IMMEDIATELY THE BILL WOULD ALSO
STATE THAT VESSEL OPERATORS WHO
KNOWINGLY DOES NOT PROVIDE THIS
ALERTED CAL ALWAYS. FULLY US IS
SUBJECT TO A CIVIL FINE OF UP TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. I WANT TO
SPECIFIED THAT THIS AMOUNT IS
ALREADY CURRENT LAW. GOVERNMENT
CODE EIGHT SIX SEVEN ZERO POINT
SIX FOUR IN AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN
NEARLY COPIES ITS EXISTING
PENALTIES GAME DEVELOPED BY AB.
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMONT I ALSO
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE CIVIL
PENALTY ONLY GOES INTO EFFECT IF
THE OPERATOR DOES NOT REPORT THE
STRIKE TO. CAL YES IF THEY
FOLLOW THE PROTOCOLS PUT IN
PLACE BY THE BILL THE PENALTY
DOES NOT COME INTO EFFECT.
MEMBERS HASN'T BEEN REPORTED THE
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
ORANGE COUNTY SUFFERED LAST YEAR
AS A RESULT OF AN ANCHOR STRIKE
TO A PIPELINE. HAS WELL EXCEEDED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. TOURISM IS
THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY AND MANY LOCAL
ATTRACTIONS AND TOURIST SPOTS
WERE CLOSED FOR GREAT PERIODS OF
TIME BUT CLEAN UP EFFORTS WERE
UNDER WAY. HAD A NOTIFICATION
MEASURES SUCH AS AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN BEEN PLACED WHEN THE
PIPELINE WAS STRUCK IN JANUARY
THE STATE COULD HAVE
INVESTIGATED AND NECESSARY
REPAIRS. COULD BEEN DONE BEFORE
THE PIPELINE BURST IN OCTOBER. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSION CONVERSATIONS WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS OF THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SO I'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO ANY OTHER-
TESTIMONY DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. NO OKAY. I
DON'T KNOW OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY-
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT. ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
AND ZERO IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
ON THIS BILL. WE HAVE WHAT AT
LEAST ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT.
TWO JUST ANOTHER MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR SHARE.
MADAM CHAIR JUST ANOTHER MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO FIRST TO LINE
FIFTY EIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE
ONES NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS STILL CAN'T
BELIEVE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION HERE IN A CLEANER
POSITION TODAY WE'D LIKE TO
THINK OF THEM REMEMBER DAVIES
FOR STOPPING COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING METHODS TO SIMPLIFY AND
IMPROVE THE BELL. AND WHILE WE
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE NEWLY AMENDED
VERSION OF THIS SO WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS REGARDING THE
CIVIL PENALTY STRUCTURE SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF ON THIS PROVISION THAT THE
GOLD REPORT THANK. YOU THANK YOU
. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE.
NINETEEN I NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. I'M SURE THERE IS NO
ENOUGH TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU I'M SITES
ONE REMIND- OUR COMMITTEE THAT
WE ARE OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE.
QUORUM YET BUT WE WILL BE VOTING
ON THE BILL BUT WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE DOES ANYBODY. HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU- WE WILL LEAVE THIS OPEN AND
WHEN WE HAVE QUORUM WILL BE ABLE
TO VOTE. THANK YOU.
READ THE OPRAH GO. WE'RE. THIS
HAS A QUICK ONE WHAT YOU NUMBER
ANYTHING COME OF THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO AND- ITEM SIX AB.
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS. PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY TEAM IN THE BILL STAKEHOLDERS
. ON A MINI AND ACTUALLY
IMPROVING THIS BILL. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COOPERATION. MY
TEAM IS. BEEN IN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ALSO WITH CAL
RECYCLE TO FINE TUNE THE BILL.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND
THE BILL'S ELIGIBILITY TO
INCLUDE COLLECTION PROGRAMS FOR
BIOMASS RECYCLING INCLUDING
COMPOSTING AND MULCHING. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
NIELSEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GALLAGHER AND PATTERSON FOR CO
AUTHORING THE MEASURE AS WELL.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX WOULD
CREATE A FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM
FOR RURAL COUNTIES. TO OFFER
COLLECTION DAYS FOR THE REMOVAL
OF LOCALIZED ACCESS WOODY
BIOMASS MATERIAL. THE BILL
PROVIDES OPTIONS FOR ROLE
RESIDENTS TO DISPOSE OF THEIR
EXCESS BIOMASS MATERIALS. WE
INTEND TO USE THE GIGI R. F.
FUNDS TO FUND THIS PROGRAM IS
THERE'S A CLEAR NEXUS BETWEEN
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND A
MEASURABLE REDUCTION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. THE
CURRENT PROBLEM EACH YEAR ROLE
CALIFORNIANS TAKE THEIR
OVERGROWTH AND PILE IT UP AND
BURNING. MANY RESORT TO THIS
METHOD OF DISPOSAL SIMPLY
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OTHER WASTE
TO REMOVE THE MATERIAL FROM ONCE
PROPERTY. THIS IS BOTH A FIRE
RISK IN ENVIRONMENTALLY DAMAGING
. THIS BILL MOVES TO REDUCE RISK
OF WILDFIRES. INCREASED
FREQUENCY OF SEVERITY OF
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
THE LAST DECADE SADLY IT ONLY
TAKES ONE CARELESS NEIGHBOR IN
THEIR BURN PILE TO POTENTIALLY
CAUSE A DISASTER THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR THE SAFE REMOVAL OF.
WOOD AND TO BREEZE. THIS BILL IS
MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
BIOMASS IS A CLEAR ALTERNATIVE
TO OPEN PILE BURNING RESULTING
IN FAR FEWER EMISSIONS WHILE
ALSO GENERATING ENERGY FOR THE
NEARBY COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL IS
A COMMONSENSE SOLUTION. THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW COUNTIES TO HOLD
WHILE MASS COLLECTION DAY SO
THAT LOCAL RESIDENTS CAN DROP
OFF THEIR BIOMASS MATERIAL FREE
OF CHARGE. SIMPLY PUT AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX PROVIDE A
SAFE OPTION FOR ROLE
CALIFORNIANS TO KEEP THEIR
PROPERTIES CLEAR OF FIRE FUELS
WHILE ALSO REDUCING OVERALL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. IN
CLOSING. WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. AND AGAIN ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE. THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS- NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO OUR A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT- JOHN KENNEDY
FROM RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND I BELIEVE HE WILL BE
TESTIFYING OVER THE PHONE
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR OUR FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S JOHN
KENNEDY I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF RC RC WERE COMPRISED
OF ELECTED SUPERVISORS FROM
THIRTY NINE COUNTY. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTEREST
IN FINDING PATHWAYS TO HELP
RURAL RESIDENTS MANDATORY
CANNOCK WASTE AND WE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS IN YOUR
COMMITTEES THE EFFORTS TO
BROADEN THE BILL TO INCLUDE
COMPOSTING AND MULCHING
FACILITIES. AS AMENDED AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX WILL HELP
RESIDENTS IN SMALLER RURAL
COUNTIES MANAGE DIFFERENT
ORGANIC WASTE STREAMS MANY OF
OUR RURAL COUNTIES ARE IN HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS THOSE AREAS
THERE SHOULD TREMENDOUS NEED FOR
FOREST HEALTH IMPROVEMENT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS.
TO REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX WILL HELP GET
THOSE MATERIALS OUT OF THE FORCE
TO BIOMASS FACILITY AND AVOID
SIGNIFICANT EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH OPEN BURNING OR NATURAL
DECOMPOSITION THE POOREST. AT
THE SAME TIME NOT ALL
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO BY
MESSAGE SO IT'S SO BY EXTENDING
THE GRANT PROGRAM TO COMPOST AND
MULCH PRODUCTION THE BILL ALSO
HELP THOSE JURISDICTIONS MANAGE
ORGANIC WASTE. AND FINALLY AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX COULD HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMPLY WITH
THE STATE'S NEW SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING REGULATIONS THE
REGULATIONS REQUIRE DIVERSION OF
ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS WE
APPRECIATE MR MATHIS BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND- URGE YOUR
ABILITY IN APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU I'M DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES- REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO NOW WILL OPEN IT
UP TO. OB TESTIMONY FROM THE
PUBLIC FIRST THE HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. C.
OPERATOR CAN YOU NOW OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY TESTIMONY
FROM THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
AGAIN IF YOU DO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE SEVEN ZERO
SIX ONE NINE ZERO. IF YOU FIND
YOURSELF THANK YOU FOR THE WRONG
BILL. YOU CAN PRESS ONE ENTER TO
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM A FOR THE
FULL FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS
THE ONLY BILL WHAT WE'RE TAKING
SPEAKERS FOR. IN A GO TO LINE.
SIXTY FIVE POINT SIXTY FIVE YOUR
ONES NO OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JULIE NOW
NOW KEEP ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WILL NOW GO TO LINE. THIRTY SIX.
THANK THIRTY SIX OR ONE IS NOW
OPEN.
AND ONCE AGAIN A LINE PRETTY
SECURE LINE IS OPEN. AND JUST A
MOMENT WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
SPEAKER WHOSE SIGNALED THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. NOW GO TO LINE. SIXTY
NINE. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN.
HEY MAN JERRY DO APOLOGIZE IT
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE SPEAKERS
WHO DID NOT WISH TO SPEAK WITH
THIS BILL. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
SPEAKERS. DID YOU SAY THERE ARE
NO MORE SPEAKERS OKAY SORRY I'M
HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING- THE
OPERATOR- FROM WHERE I'M SITTING
AT LEAST OKAY THANK YOU I'M SO
WE HAVE NO MORE- SPEAKERS ALL
OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS K. THERE ARE NONE- WE'RE
OPERATING AS A SUB COMMITTEE WE
WILL VOTE ON THIS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MANAGER.
ASSEMBLY.
OKAY NEXT WILL BE WEARING AN
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN I'M BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR WHEN PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO START WHEN YOU'RE READY GREAT
TIMING- MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CALIFORNIA HAS
A LONG HISTORY OF CELEBRATING
THE UNIQUE QUALITIES OF OUR
COASTLINE WITH OUR STATE LEADING
THE COUNTRY IN PROMOTING ACCESS
AND PROTECTION OF OUR SURFING
ZONES SIMILAR TO OUR STATE
SCENIC HIGHWAY DESIGNATION AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. WILL
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA CALL
COASTAL CONCERT CONSERVANCY TO
ESTABLISH CRITERIA AND THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
DESIGNATING AN AREA OF THE
COASTLINE AS A STATE SURFING
RESERVE THIS SEGMENT DESIGNATION
WILL SERVE TO RECOGNIZE THE
CULTURAL HISTORICAL ECONOMIC AND
ECOLOGICAL IMPORTANCE OF
CALIFORNIA SURF ZONES WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH MAYOR PRO TEM.
MIKE POSEY. THANK YOU MISS
IRWIN- WE'RE READY FOR-
TESTIMONY FROM MIKE POSEY FROM
THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR MR POSEY.
MADAM CHAIR IT APPEARS THAT THAT
PARTICULAR SPEAKER IS NOT ON THE
CONFERENCE YET. OKAY WELL
MICHAEL REALLY LIKED THE IDEA OF
BEING ABLE TO DESIGNATE A STATE
SURFING RESERVE ESPECIALLY BEING
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF- SOME THAT ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THIS PREVENTING
FUTURE DEVELOPMENTS I WANT TO
STRESS THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY SO IF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DOES NOT WANT
TO BE DESIGNATED. OF A SURFING
RESERVE THAN THEY DO NOT HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE APPLICATION
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT
WAS YOUR ONLY WITNESS RIGHT YES
OKAY SO WE WILL GO AHEAD IN- SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WANTS
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN THE HEARING
ROOM. CASEY NINE OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES-
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN SO
WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BOB THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE PERSON TO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE TWELVE
LINE TWELVE YOUR ONES NO OPEN.
H. R. YES THANK YOU THIS IS-
MIKE POSEY FROM THE CITY
PLANNING TO BEACH. GOOD MORNING.
OR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN- AGAIN MY
NAME IS MIKE POSE IN THE MAYOR
MAYOR PRO TEM OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH. IN ON BEHALF OF OUR
CITY'S INTER GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. THE
FULL CITY COUNCIL BE TAKING A
POSITION AT OUR NEXT COUNCIL
MEETING IN APRIL THE FIFTH.
THANK YOU KNOW THE CITY
HUNTINGTON BEACH OF THE COASTAL
COMMUNITY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS WITH THE RICH
SURFING HISTORY. AND A STRONG
COASTAL IDENTITY I HAVE BEEN A
RESIDENT OF CITY THANK YOU BEACH
FOR THE PAST TWENTY THREE YEARS
AND HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND. THE
IMPACT THAT SURFING HAS MADE ON
OUR COMMUNITY. THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH IS COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS SEARCH CITY USA
AND HOST WORLD CLASS SURFING
COMPETITIONS SUCH AS THE U. S.
OPEN OF SURFING. AROUND
INTERNATIONAL SURFING MUSEUM
WHICH DISPLAYS MANY OF THE GREAT
SIR COURTS AND HISTORY. OF THE
SPORT FROM AROUND THE WORLD. AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN WILL
CREATE A PROCESS. TO THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY TO DESIGNATE
SURFING RESERVES IN ORDER
RECOGNIZE THE CULTURAL
HISTORICAL. ECONOMIC AND
ECOLOGICAL IMPORTANCE OF WAVES
AND SURFING THE CALIFORNIA.
BISTATIC NATIONAL GO TO REVIEW
PROCESS AT THE CONSERVANCY AND
WILL LOOK AT THE FACTORS THAT
MAKE SURFING COMMUNITY. GREAT
INCLUDING WEIGHT QUALITY AND
CONSISTENCY. SIR CULTURE HISTORY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CHARACTERISTICS. I SURE HOPE WE
QUALIFY. THE CONTROLLED
APPLICATION PROCESS BUILT INTO
THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
THE WORTHY SECTIONS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE ARE
DESIGNATED. AS STATE SURFING
RESERVE SO THAT THEY ARE NOT
OVER POPULATED OR OVER
DESIGNATED. DESIGNATIONS ESTATE
SURFING RESERVES ARE INTENDED TO
PROMOTE AND PAY HOMAGE TO
SURFING'S ENVIRONMENTAL CULTURAL
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE. THE
COULD ALSO BE A MARKETING AND
TOURISM DRIVER FOR THE ENTIRE%
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO EXPRESS OUR
OUR SUPPORT AT LEAST IN THE
IRISH SEA IN HUNTINGTON BEACH.
AND FUTURE ANTICIPATED SUPPORT
FROM THE COUNCIL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MR POSEY. LINE.
SEVENTY SIX. ONE SEVENTY TWO ONE
IS NOW OPEN. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN- IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. IT APPEARS WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU I'M
NEXT I'LL OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. CASEY
NONE OF WERE- SIR JUST A
COMMENT- APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- EVEN I
REPRESENT THE NORTH COAST WHICH-
IS A COLD SURFING AREA- BUT THE
RESTORED STILL SURFING ALONG
THERE AND- IF THE BILL PASSED
OUT OF COMMITTEE I'D LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. THROUGH IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WERE
OPERATING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
NOW BUT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON YOUR BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SURE. YES ME.
THE. BUT WHAT WAS A TYPICAL
PROCESS YEAH. YEAH YEAH. WHICH
WAS THE FIRST. TWENTY CITIZENS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
THINK YOU CAN START WIH- TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX FIRST YES PLEASE
GOOD THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR-
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING ELIZABETH FOR
HER WORK ON THIS ANALYSIS. OF I
WILL. GO AHEAD AND HANDED OVER
TO MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TODAY
I HAVE- INDICATE WHAT THE POLICY
AND OUTREACH CONSULTANT AT
CLIMATE RESOLVE. THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. AND DR MARK- FOOD OUR
NECK DIRECTOR OF CLINICAL
SERVICES OF V. P. US ACUTE CARE
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
A DISRUPTOR CAN YOU OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR THOSE TWO
WITNESSES PLEASE.
MISTRUST RATE CAN YOU OPEN THE
PHONE LINES UP FOR THOSE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SIX. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANDREA WEBER ON THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTORATE CLIMATE
RESULTS BUT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WE'VE BEEN WORKING
TO ADAPT LOS ANGELES TO EXTREME
HEAT FOR THE PAST DECADE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE P. TWENTY
SEVEN SIX HE EXPLAINED IN A
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE PROGRAM.
BEFORE IT BEGAN I'D LIKE TO
THANK CHAIR THREE OF US FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE ON HER
STUFF FOR ALL THE EXTRA WORK BE
DONE BEHIND THE SCENES. THIS
BILL RECOGNIZES THAT IF YOU WERE
TO STOP EMITTING GREENHOUSE
GASES TOMORROW EXTREME HEAT AS A
BEACON FOR A FUTURE FOR MANY
DECADES TO COME. THAT'S WHY IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE PREPARE AN
ADAPTER COMMUNITIES TODAY. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SIX DOES JUST
THAT. I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THREE
KEY POINTS FIRST HE IS A BIG
PROBLEM IN THE STATE'S RESPONSE
IS PIECEMEAL AND INADEQUATE. TO
DATE EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING A WARMER CLIMATE OVER
THAT OF THE LAST CENTURY. YEP
THE STATE'S RESPONSE REMAINS
FRAGMENTED AND UNCOORDINATED
SECOND AB TWENTY SEVENTY SIX THE
DRESS OF THE GROWING PROBLEM BY
COORDINATING THE WORK OF OVER A
DOZEN FREE AGENCY. REQUIRING
EVALUATION OF ALL HE PROGRAMS
AND PROJECTS AND ESTABLISHES A
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WILL
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS TO ADDRESS EXTREME
HEAT. THIRD PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX IS THE CENTRAL TO
PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN AND
OTHER VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
FROM THE INCREASING THREAT OF
EXTREME HEAT. AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SIX WILL SAVE LIVES CORRECT THE
POLICY GAP IN THE STATE
SEPARATES THE BUILD RESILIENCE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE FOR THIS AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A DIVERSE SET OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING PUBLIC
HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FAITH
BASED NON PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU AGAIN
SHOULD BE LESS CLEAR LEADERSHIP
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MARK IN IS
IN RETAIL ON THE LINE. THAT THAT
WASN'T THE CASE DOES IT DOES
OKAY. IS MARK OF NEXT. IT HI I'M
DOCTOR HERE TO IN A POSITION IN
LOS IN THE PAST PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS THE LARGEST CHAPTER
IN THE NATION AND ALSO SERVICE
THE MANAGING EDITOR FOR THE
JOURNAL OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HELP. MY TESTIMONY BASED ON MY
PERSONAL EPERIENCE AS AN
EMERGENCY CONDITION COMBINED
WITH KERRY BEAT MEDICAL
RESEARCH. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK ON A. B. TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX THE EXTREME HEAT AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE PROGRAM.
OUR STATE IS GETTING HOTTER AND
IT IMPACTING OUR HEALTH RIGHT
NOW THE HEADLINE NUMBERS TO KEEP
RELATED FATALITIES WHICH
SURPASSED ALL OTHER NATURAL
WEATHER EVENTS. HAIL IN
COMPARISON TO THE FULL IMPACT OF
INCREASED T. WHICH IS GROSSLY
UNDER REPORTED. EACH THAT'S
DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO KEEP
RATES ARE USUALLY COVERED BY
SPECIFIC. POPULATIONS MOST AT
RISK ARE ELDERLY LIVING LEVEL.
PEOPLE WELCOME MIKE BY CHRONIC
ILLNESS INCLUDING MENTAL
ILLNESS. THOSE WHO MUST WORK
OUTDOORS OR EVEN INDOORS WITH
INADEQUATE COOLING. AND
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. NOW IT'S OF LARGE
DATASETS EVEN MORE WORRISOME
STORY THAN THE HEADLINE NUMBERS
THAT'S THE ONLY INCREASE ACROSS
THE BOARD AS THE TEMPERATURE
RISES MORE GAS MORE HEART
ATTACKS AND STROKES MORE
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS MORE
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE MORE
MENTAL ILLNESS FINDING WE
CONFIRMED A LARGE STUDY IN THE
JOURNAL OF THE AMHS LAST MONTH.
DECIDED TO MAKE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR
WHY WE MUST DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS MELTING. HEALTH CRISIS SO
WHAT CAN WE DO. WE NEED TO
PREVENT EXPO TO ELEVATED
PARTICULARLY FOR LONG PERIODS OF
TIME BY CALLING OUR COMMUNITIES.
COOL REAL SHADE TREES PUBLICLY
BILLION TUBS THAT CONTAIN COOL
RECORD AREAS AND BACK UP ENERGY
SYSTEMS COOLER BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER MULTI
BENEFIT PROJECTS. SUCH AS COOL
STREETS THAT WE COLLECT HE
COMBINED THE TREE PLANTING ARE
ALL EXAMPLES OF HOW GOVERNMENT
CAN PREVENT EXCESSIVE HEAT
EXPOSURE PARTICULARLY IN OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. WHO
MAY NOT HAVE THE MEANS THE
BOUNCE BACK AFTER THE DISASTER
STRIKES. THE GRANT IN AID. TWO
OH TWO SIX PROVIDE OUR CAN THE
AVENUE INVEST CRY. WHICH WILL
BENEFIT THE HELP AND COMMUNITY
FOR NEW TO COME. WE CAN PREVENT
HARM BY CENTER BITING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL
COMPREHENSIVE SUITE ACTION PLANS
THAT SPECIFY WHITE SHEET
REDUCING STRATEGY. BACK
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SIX WITH
COMPLICATED BY COORDINATING
ACTIVITIES A FINAL AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND COLLECTING
THE NECESSARY DATA TO FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS SO WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
LOOKS GOOD. I'M MONITORING THE
DATA CAREFULLY YOU WILL KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE TO INTERVENE WITH
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND.
STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT WILL
INDOOR. AB TWENTY SEVEN SIX
FOCUS IS THE EIGHT EFFORTS ON
MITIGATING THE IMPACT THE DEADLY
. THANK YOU OUR COULD. EVERY
THEY NEED TO BE PROTECT EFFECT.
I AM HERE BE FORTY COLLECT. AND
I AM THE- AND- OF THE DEPARTMENT
IN CHARGE OF OUR RESPONSE TO
INTERSTATE. ENVIRONMENT THANK
YOU TO THE KITTY CARE TIME AND
ATTENTION I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I BUILT ON
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVENTY SIX
EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT OPERATORS ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB. TWENTY SEVENTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR READY FOR
COMMENTS NOW YOU CAN PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. TO
THIS BILL. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE. THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MITCH SNIDER WAS THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
EXPORT. THANK YOU LINE. SIXTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THE SOME OF THEM AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY UP
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES ONE OF
THE STATE'S LEADING PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX WE RECOGNIZE THE
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ON SYSTEMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AND VULNERABLE
THANK YOU NEEDS ARE WHICH NAME
AN ORGANIZATIONAL LEADER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT.
LINE. SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TIM CROMARTIE
A POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
LEAGUE THE KEY TO ADDRESSING
RIVAL JUSTICE ISSUES IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. BLIND FORTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TASHA NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
FOREST COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. LINE. EIGHTY TWO. I NEEDED TO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRITNEY
BENEFITING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR THE
PREVENTION OF CRUELTY TO ANIMALS
IN SUPPORT. LINE. EIGHTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID
AS A VETO SUCH A CHARACTER WITH
A RP CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN
THE STATE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO ZERO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU
. LINE. SEVENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE SCOTT
SATTLER- REPRESENTING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
LINE EIGHTY THREE. THIS IS
SANTIAGO CALIFORNIA BY MEANS OF
OTHERS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO DO A
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT. ON
THIS BILL. YOU CHECK THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
BRING ABOUT TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM ANYONE AND- LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. C. N.
NOBODY. THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE MEMBERS. C. N.
NOBODY AFTER WHICH I CLOSED-
THANK GOD I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH. I THINK
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY EIGHT. SALAS IS AREAS
OF. EIGHT OF GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING ELIZABETH FOR HER WORK
ON THIS ANALYSIS AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT ESTABLISHES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A STATE WIDE HE
RANKING PROCESS BASED ON
PROJECTED HEALTH IMPACTS AND
METEOROLOGIST GOAL OF DATA SUCH
AS MAXIMUM AND MINIMUM
TEMPERATURES AS WELL AS HOW LONG
A HEAT WAVE ISN'T DISSIPATED TO
PROCESS. THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO
STUDY INSURED AND UNINSURED COST
RELATED TO PAST HEAT WAVES AS
CALIFORNIA FACES XCELERATED
RISKS FROM CLIMATE INTENSIFIED
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS ADVANCED
EARLY WARNING IS NEEDED MORE
THAN EVER. THIS SYSTEM WILL BE
PROACTIVELY USED TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND PROPERTY I'M
TODAY. UP TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT I HAVE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND LEWIS
BLOOMBERG CONSULTANT FOR THE
ADRIENNE ARSHT ROCKEFELLER
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMISSIONER ON ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE. YES I AM IT'S ALL YOURS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU JEFFREY
ABOUT THEM THANK YOU BY SURPRISE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE POP
PROUD TO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO THIRTY EIGHT TONY AUTHORED BY
CHERRY ABOUT THEM AS A MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA TO CREATE A FIRST
IN THE NATION HEATH RANKING AND
ADVANCE WARNING SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. CLIMATE CHANGES AND
GENTRIFYING AS WE ARE NOW
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS- MAKE OUT
PART OF THEM WHAT TRAGIC IMPACT
THE CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES HEATWAVES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE DEATHS THAN
ALL OTHER EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS WE HEARD
FROM THE LAST TESTIMONY
ESPECIALLY PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE SENIORS AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES MANY
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ALREADY EXPERIENCING THE IMPACT
OF EXTREME HEAT. EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE IN THE MONTH OF MARCH THIS
WEEK WE ARE FACING A SIGNIFICANT
EARLY HEAT WAVE METEOROLOGISTS
ARE PREDICTING TEMPERATURES MORE
THAN TWENTY DEGREES ABOVE
AVERAGE IN SOME PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA TO AVOID UNNECESSARY
DEATHS AND HEALTH IMPACTS WE
NEED TO ACT NOW INCLUDING
IMPROVING OUR RISK COMMUNICATION
TOOLS AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT WHAT THE DIPLOMAT A KEY
RECOMMENDATION OF MY DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE CLIMATE INSURANCE
SUPPORT. TO RANK HEATWAVE AND
CREATE A STATEWIDE EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO AVOID DEATH
ILLNESS AND SIGNIFICANT. OTHER
UNINSURED COSTS THE REPORT WAS
DEVELOPED BY A GROUP THAT I
CONVENE AN ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND PUBLIC
POLICY EXPERTS PURSUANT TO MY
SENATE BILL THIRTY FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN I WAS IN THE STATE
SENATE HE RANKING CATEGORIES IN
AB TWENTY TWENTY TO THIRTY EIGHT
WILL PROVIDE STRONGER RISK
COMMUNICATION THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY TRIGGER POLICY MEASURES
SUCH AS DECREASING PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY OF FIGHT LIMITING
CERTAIN ELECTRIC ELECTRICITY
USE. OPENING CLOSING CENTER AND
ADDING MORE HEALTH CARE CAPACITY
TO INTERVENE AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT ALSO DIRECTS MY
DEPARTMENT TO STUDY INSURED. AND
UNINSURED COSTS WE TO PASS P.
WAVES WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
INSIGHT INTO A HEAT BUT GAPS AND
PROMOTE MORE EFFECTIVE ROOF
COMING. AND PLANNING THE CURRENT
BUDGET- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO CONTAINS MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OVER SEVERAL YEARS TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE IMPACTS FROM EXTREME
HEAT. I BELIEVE THAT THE MEASURE
WOULD ALIGN WITH THE FUNDING OUR
INTENT BY PROVIDING A CLEAR
COMMUNICATION TOOL TO WARN
MORRIBLE COMMUNITIES OF
IMPENDING. DANGER OF HEATING
VENTS I BELIEVE EXTREME HEAT
WAVES ARE THE DEADLIEST CLIMATE
THREAT THAT CALIFORNIA FACES
TODAY AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. IF NEEDED TO NOW
GIVE ADVANCE WARNING IRAQIS THE
WAVES THAT WE CAN CONFRONT THE
GROWING THREAT OF EXTREME HEAT
AND SAVE LIVES TOTAL REASONS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH C<c.cyan> NECK</c>
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. YES OOD
AFTERNOON I AM LUIS BLOOMBERG
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ADRIENNE ARSHT ROCKEFELLER
FOUNDATION RESILIENCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
EIGHT. ARCHROCK CENTER IS
BECAUSE HE'S WORKING TO SUPPORT
HEATWAVE RANKING SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES AND GLOBALLY.
I ALSO SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
CLINTON INSURANCE WORKING GROUP
CONVENED BY CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LARA WHO JUST SPOKE
AND WE THANK YOU A CONVENTIONAL
ARE FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS AND WE
THANK YOU CHAIR RIVAS FOR YOUR
INSPIRING LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
EIGHT. THIRTY EXTREME HELP HEY
INTRIGUED HE IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND A CLIMATE RESILIENT
CHALLENGE IT IMPACTS OUR HEALTH
AND MENTAL ACUITY REDUCES WORKER
SAFETY AND PRODUCTIVITY
INCREASES CHILDREN'S LEARNING
LOWER AGRICULTURAL YIELDS MELTS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALL
THE OTHER IMPACTS THE OCCURRED
ABOUT- AND AS YOU HEARD ALSO. HE
AFFECTS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND OTHER PROBLEMS
POSSIBLE POPULATIONS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY HE KILLED
MORE THAN ANY OTHER QUITE DRIVEN
ABOUT YEAH IT'S CONSIDERED
MISSILE KILLER BECAUSE BE AND-
WHO NOT UNDER. THAT HUMAN ANY.
DEVASTATION IT CAUSES. IF WE
DON'T KNOW HOW SERIOUS THE
PROBLEM IS AND HOW MUCH IT COST
US TODAY HOW CAN WE RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT WILL PLUG IN THESE
TWO FOUNDATIONAL GAPS IN THE
STATE'S FLEDGLING EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THIS GROWING THREAT. AND
AT ITS COULD NOT CONTROL ARE
POINTING OUT BOTH OF THESE
CORRECT AND THESE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT YEAH
COMMITTEE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
WHO OF COURSE. FIRST AB TWENTY
TO THIRTY WILL INCREASE PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF THE SEVERITY OF THE
RISK BY IMPROVING WARNING
SYSTEM. CURRENT WARNING SYSTEMS
DO NOT FULLY ACCOUNT FOR EACH
RISK HUMAN HEALTH AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT FOUR SIX THIS WEEK
OUTCOMES INTO A NEW SYSTEM. THAT
WILL ENABLE REGENCY CATEGORY
WAYS BY THE PROJECTED IMPACT ON
PEOPLE. CATEGORIZATION ALLOWS
FOR BETTER DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
HIGHER IMPACT PUBLIC MESSAGING
THAT IS TARGETED AT VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IMPROVES EFFICIENCY
OF PUBLIC SPENDING AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE LIVES. SECOND
THE SECOND GAP IS WE DON'T KNOW
THE COST TO BE TO CALIFORNIA. AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL AN ANALYSIS
PREPARED FOR THE OUR TRUCK
CENTER ESTIMATES THAT EACH YEAR
PETER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ONE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN LOST
WORKER PRODUCTIVITY ALONE. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT REQUIRES
A COST ANALYSIS OF HEAT WAVES
THAT CALIFORNIA IT WILL IDENTIFY
WHO THEIR CELLS COST. THE
FINDINGS OF THE REPORT
UNDERWRITE NEW FINANCIAL
INSTRUMENTS THAT WILL TRANSFER
RISK LOWERING COSTS AND
IMPROVING PROTECTION BEFORE AND
DURING HEATWAVES. INCREASED
AWARENESS OF THE RISK IS THE
GATEWAY TO ADDRESSING THE
GROWING PROBLEM OF EXTREME HEAT
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AGAIN
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK CLEAR AYE THOSE. AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
OPERATORS ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT AND OR OPPOSITION. TO
THIS BILL. THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IT'S TIME. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE. THIRTY THREE. YOUR LINE
IS NOW WHICH MMHM MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. LINE
SEVENTY NINE. ME. FIND SEVENTY
NINE I APOLOGIZE YOU'RE ONE IS
NOW OPEN. SCOTT SATTLER ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. I AM. SEVENTY
SEVEN. AFTERNOON AGAIN- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRINGING
BENEFITS ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR THE
PREVENTION OF CRUELTY TO ANIMALS
IN SUPPORT.
I NEED TO THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. FIND. EIGHTY SIX. DALY
BEAT AGAIN FIFTY TRACTOR WITH A
RP CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TO THREE THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN LAYS IN GERMAN FOR THOSE
OF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE A
DIFFERENT. I NEED THE THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
pBUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WE SHOULD WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. CENA AND BRING IT TO
THECOMMITTEE ANYTHING FROM A
MEMBERS. CNN MANAGER WOULD LIKE
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM-
SECRETARY Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TO REVERSE HERE RIVAS HERE
FLORA FLOOR HERE FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA MATHIS WE'RE MATHIS HERE
MCCARTY CARDIUM MURATSUCHI
ROBERT RIVAS SEYARTO HERE HERE
HERE STONE WOULD. CLICK HERE.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM I'M NEXT I
THINK WE'RE READY FOR MISTER
SALAS- ITEM. THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS I PRESENT BEFORE YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
WOULD EXEMPT WATER WELL PROJECTS
AND DOMESTIC WELL PROJECTS. FROM
SEEK WHAT WILL IF THE WELLS HAVE
BEEN ONLY IF THE WELLS HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED BY THE STATE BOARD AS
HIGH RISK OR MEDIUM RISK OF
FAILURE BUT THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND WOULD MITIGATE OR
PREVENT A FAILURE. OF THE WELL
THAT WOULD LEAVE RESIDENTS
WITHOUT AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
SAFE AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER
THIS BILL HELPS STREAMLINE
CRITICAL WATER WELL PROJECTS AT
TO PREEMPTIVELY ADDRESS WELL
FAILURE TO PREVENT RULE
COMMUNITIES FROM BEING LEFT WITH
NO SOURCE OF SAFE DRINKING
WATER- WITH THAT I DO HAVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE A CHRIS ANDERSON
AND LESLIE BATIC ADVOCATE WITH
AQUA AND NATHAN OLSON THE CITY
MANAGER OF LAMAR. K. THANK YOU
SO WILL GO AHEAD AND START- WITH
MR ANDERSON. IS HE IN THE ROOM.
OR AFP TEST FINE OVER THE PHONE
. ON THE PHONE OKAY OPERATOR
WE'RE READY FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
WE HAVE TO MR CHRIS ANDERSON AND
MR NATHAN OLSON.
AND WITNESSES IF YOU ARE HERE
PLEASE PLEASE SEND ME YOUR LINE. MADAM CHAIR IT APPEARS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE EITHER ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS. THIS IS THIS IS NATHAN
ALTAMONT. PARDON ME OKAY GO
AHEAD MISTER OLSON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE HEARD TODAY AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD SO AGAIN NATHAN ALL
FROM THE CITY MANAGER OF LAMAR
CALIFORNIA WE'RE LOCATED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY TWO AND OUR
COUNCILS ALREADY TAKEN THE STEPS
TO PROVIDE A LETTER OF SUPPORT-
A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY TWO WOULD
BE. AN IMMEDIATE RELIEF AND
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS TO GET
DRINKING WATER AVAILABILITY. IN
A MORE TIMELY MANNER WITHOUT THE
RISK OF LITIGATION. AREAS WERE
THE STATE WATER BOARD TEAMS HIGH
RISK AREA- A TYPICAL WELL BILL
YOU'RE A REPLACEMENT WELL WOULD
BE DEAD WITHIN A HUNDRED FIFTY
FEET FROM THAT FAILED WELL. AND
WE ARE SEVERELY OVER DRAFTED-
AREA- IN IN OUR REGION AND WELL
FILL YEARS AND SUBSIDENCE ISSUES
ARE A DAILY OCCURRENCE FOR US
THOUGH. THIS BILL IS A GREAT
STEP IN THE FIFTIES ASSISTANCE
ANYTHING KEEPING THE WATER
FLOWING AND IT ALSO HELPS REDUCE
THE- THE POTENTIAL FOR
LITIGATION. IF WE CAN GET AN
EXAM FROM THE SEQUEL PROCESS
BECAUSE THAT ADDS MONTHS TO THE
TIMELINE. AND- THAT DOES AFFECT
THE AVAILABILITY OF DRINKING
WATER FOR RESIDENTS AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION WATER AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE MISTER CHRIS ANDERSON ON
THE LINE. OKAY I BELIEVE WE
DON'T LET'S JUST GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY CASEY NINE OPERATOR Q.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES TO
FURTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL ONLY. HOW CAN. WE GO TO
LINE. SEVENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF BUT OCCASIONALLY
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
APOLOGY. HAVING A LITTLE TROUBLE
GETTING THRILLED- BUT WE'RE IN
SUPPORT TODAY THE SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO- YEAH IF I CAN BE AFFORDED
THE TIME I'D LIKE TO JUST
PROVIDE A BRIEF TESTIMONY. OKAY-
PEOPLE UP BY THE DISCRETIONARY
AGENCY ACTION WITH POTENTIAL TO
CUT SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT THE ISSUANCE OF A
PERMIT CAN BE CONSIDERED A
PROJECT. UNDERSEA COAL WHERE THE
PHYSICAL CHANGE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT CAN RESULT FROM THE
PERMITTED ACTIVITY. PERMITTED
SHOW IT CAN BE TO FIND EITHER AT
THE DISCRETIONARY OR MINISTERIAL
WARNED APPROVAL DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE EXERCISE OF JUDGMENT BY THE
AGENCY THE PROPOSED MINISTERIAL
IN NATURE AND EXEMPT FROM
SEQUEL. I TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CASE
ANALYZE WHETHER A COUNTY
ORDINANCE CLASSIFYING. ALL WELL
CONSTRUCTION PERMITS THAT. WELL
PROJECT MONEY CATEGORY BASIS.
EXCEPT WHERE VARIANCE WAS
GRANTED IT COMPLIED WITH THE
COURT THE COURT HELD THAT
CLASSIFYING ALL NON VARIANTS
WELL CONSTRUCTION PERMITS. AS
MINISTERIAL PROJECT VIOLATED
SPEAK WHAT. ITS RECENT ROLLING
HAVE PLAYED MORE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT. CONSERVE DALY
TREATING WELL REPLACEMENT
PROJECT THAT THE SCRIPT UNITY
AND THEREFORE REQUIRING A SEQUIN
OUTFIT. IT IS THE TIME SENSITIVE
NATURE MATIC WELL PROJECTS
STREAMLINED PERMITTING IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE RESIDENTS
CAN MAINTAIN ACCESS TO SAFE AND
CLEAN DRINKING WATER. IT WILL
PROVIDE TE VERY NARROW
EXEMPTION THE QUICK THEM SIMPLE
WATER CERTAIN WHILE PROJECT
DOMESTIC WHILE PROJECTS- AND-
THE BILL WOULD HELP STREAMLINE
THESE PROJECTS TO PREEMPTIVELY
ADDRESS WILL YOU WELFARE GET
FAILURE SO FOR THESE. REASONS
ARE QUITE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. LOCAL THERE ARE
GOING TO GO TO LINE. SEVENTY
TWO. HI JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. LINE.
THIRTY ONE. LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ERIN WILLIAMS OF
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU. LINE. EIGHTY THREE. THIS IS
SANTIAGO WITH CALIFORNIAN BY
VOTERS WE ARE IN A POSITION
UNTIL THE BILL IS AMENDED OR WE
WILL BE IN A POSITION. I MANAGER
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON
WHO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
FIFTEEN OF THE MOMENT. WELL NOW
GO TO LINE. NINETY TWO- I WOULD
NEED BE ONE STEP SHORT OF JAIL
BECAUSE- CHAD OF LETTERS DURING
MARTIN OF DELUDED CHECK COULD BE
IN THE WATER BILLS CHORE PLANTED
HERE TO SALTY. OR OR AWAY FROM.
ARE GENERATED WE NEVER COULD
THEIR- THANKS. OKAY THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU UP NEXT
WILL OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HE'S
THIRTY NINE- MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- IS
SOMEBODY WHOSE HOMETOWN IS THE
CITY WITHOUT WATER AFFORDABLE
CALIFORNIA- THE SYSTEM THAT I
WISH WOULD AHEAD SOONER- AS
WE'RE FACING THE LAST DROUGHT IS
WERE COMING INTO THE THIRD YEAR
OF. A NEW RECORD BREAKING
DROUGHT I GREATLY APPRECIATE
THIS BILL OF LOVE THE JOINT
AUTHORS TO SHOW BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE NEED TO GET. WELL
DONE WHEN THEY GO OUT- WITHOUT
ANY HURDLES IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. AND KEEPS COMMUNITIES
HOLE SO MEMBERS I'D ASK FOR
SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU. THE
NUMBER. THANK YOU THANK YOU UP
MISTER SOUTH SIDES WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND WOULD YOU
LIKE MY POSTS GO HEAD YES AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITTEES
WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS THEY
WERE- THINK THEY STRENGTHEN THE
BILL THEY GET TO A REAL PROBLEM
WHICH IS MAKING SURE THAT ARE
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER
THESE COMMUNITIES OF THEIR DIRE
NEED. RIGHT WE'VE SEEN THAT NOT
ONLY LIKE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS ADDED TULARE COUNTY BUT
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE AS
WELL ESPECIALLY AS WE FACE THESE
HISTORIC DROUGHTS AND AS WE FACE
IS HISTORIC PROBLEM SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITTEES
WORK. THANK YOU. TWO WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR MISTER WOULD SECONDED
BY MR FLORA. I'M SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR RIVAS HI
RIVAS BY FLORA. FLORA I FRIEDMAN
. GARCIA MATHIS MATHIS BY
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI. ROBERT RIVAS SEYARTO
HI THEY ARE TO AYE STONE. WOOD
WOOD I. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THAT SIX
ZERO I WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK. WHOSE
NAME. OKAY. THANK YOU BETTER BE
CAREFUL OKAY I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
A B. TWO OH SEVEN FIVE FIRST
PLEASE GO AHEAD GREAT THE FIRST
LET ME JUST THINK BOTH- YOU AND
SHARE YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL YOUR HELP. THIS BILL IS A
FAIRLY SIMPLE BUT AFFECTIVE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION-
ADOPT- BUILDING CODES FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY CONSIDER FOR
ADOPTION- BY THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION- IT MIMICS
THE POLICY- IT MIMICS THAT
POLICY BEFORE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
THE BILL EMPOWERS THE CC TO USE
THEIR EXPERTISE TO DEVELOP
NECESSARY COST EFFECTIVE EVEN
CHARGING STANDARDS FOR ALL
BUILDINGS PRIOR TO THE FINAL B.
S. C. ADOPTION- CC YOU'RE
OBVIOUSLY ARE THE FEW FEES THE
EXPERT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE THE RIGHT DEPARTMENT TO
HANDLE THIS WITH THE SCIENCE
ONE. WOULD DECIDE MISS KIM STONE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR STORAGE AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION AND I'M- SHARE
NUMBER NOT JUST THE BIGGER PER
THIS IS. AT YOU SO MUCH- TO THE
MEMBER TO FOR YOUR- ON THIS
ISSUE- IN. EVEY CHAR AT THAT'S
THEY YOU BUILD THE BUILDING IS
BOTH RELIGIOUS EASIER CHEAPER.
THAN DOING IT THEREAFTER IT ALSO
ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS TO DRIVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND HELPS S.
CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONS TO MORE
CLEAN ENERGY. NEW BUILDINGS THAT
ALREADY HAVE A- SALUTE
REQUIREMENTS AND A SOLAR PLUS
EVEY OR EVEN SOLAR PLUS
BATTERIES PLUS ELECTRIC VEHICLES
THAT MEANS LESS NEED FOR
TRANSMISSION- AND THE ENERGY
THAT IS CREATED THEIR ON SITE
CAN THEN BE USED- ON SITE
REDUCING THE NEED FOR.
ADDITIONAL ON TRANSMISSION LINES
AND COSTS FOR THOSE AND OTHER
REASONS THIS IS A REALLY GREAT
BILL AND THAT CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IS PROUD
TO SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION- SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN IT UP- TO THE PUBLIC
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. SEE NON
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR AB. TWENTY SEVENTY
FIVE WE'RE TAKING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS. ONE ZERO.
WE HAVE AT LEAST A TWO PEOPLE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
. JUST A MOMENT. GOING TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY. GET UP TO ENSURE
MEMBERS BRADY GARDEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO-
SEEING FUTURE AMENDMENTS AND
TALKING MORE ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU HAVE A
GOOD ONE. LINE. NINETY TWO- I
NINETY TWO. MADAM CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU NEXT
I'LL OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
K. C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BUT THE PHONE AGAIN WOULD
JUST THINK THIS IS A- GREAT.
POLICY TO START AND CONTINUE OUR
DOBSON TOWARDS ELECTRIC VEHICLES
WITHOUT RESPECT FOR ESCRIBIR.
THANK YOU. TWO I HAVE A MOTION.
A SECOND NO ONE WANTS. ALL
SECOND. YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER MCCARTY SECONDED BY
MYSELF THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JERRY THIS
AYE RIVAS HI FLORA. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA MATHIS.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI. ROBERT RIVAS SEYARTO
NUMBER. STONE. WHAT WOULD I. THE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR. MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
SO NEXT YOU ARE. THIS IS A PLACE
IN OUR CALL EXISTING YES. THE
NEXT WE HAVE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX ZERO SEVEN BIG BIG
RED OF GERMANY FIRST THANK YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FIVE
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- THE IMAGES OF THE
BILL IS OUR SAN FRANCISCO FIRE
DEPARTMENT HAS IDENTIFIED A
PROPERTY SITE. IN SOME PARCELS
CURRENTLY MANAGE BAR OUR PORT OF
SAN FRANCISCO UNDER THE STATE'S
PUBLIC TRUST BECAUSE IT'S RIGHT
IN OUR BED. IN THE FALLS UNDER
THE BURDEN ACT REQUIREMENTS AS A
IN THIS IS A SUITABLE HOME FOR A
NEW OF FIRE DEPARTMENT TRAINING
FACILITY OF WHICH NOT ONLY OUR
DEPARTMENT WILL USE BUT OTHER
DEPARTMENTS IN THE BAY AREA WILL
BE USED- THIS PROPOSED TRAINING
FACILITY WILL REPLACE AN
EXISTING FACILITY. ON TREASURE
ISLAND WHICH ISN'T AVAILABLE
WHICH IS NOT GONNA BE AVAILABLE
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- THE
PARCELS IN THE BILL COULD NOT BE
USED FOR ANY RECREATIONAL
PURPOSE AND THEY DON'T PROVIDE
ANY FINANCIAL BENEFITS TO THE
PUBLIC AND THEREFORE THEY CAN'T
BE SOLD ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO BE
SOLD- IN ORDER FOR THE PROPERTY
TO BE USED AS A FIRE. FIRE
DEPARTMENT TRAINING FACILITY- WE
NEED TO AMEND THE BURDEN ACT
THROUGH LEGISLATION THAT OR
BRING THIS BILL SO THIS BILL
WOULD LIFT THE PUBLIC TRUST IN
THE BURDEN APARTMENTS TO ALLOW
THOSE PARCELS- TO BE USED BY THE
CITY TO UTILIZE IT FOR
EARTHQUAKE SAFETY AND- EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TRAINING. AND I HAVE.
SHE IS. THANK YOU FOR. PERFECT-
AND THEY WE DO HAVE OUR CHIEF
CHIEF NEW FOR THE CHIEF
DEPARTMENT ONLINE TO- ADDED
WITNESSED. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD MY NAME IS
JEANINE NICHOLSON AND I AM YOUR
ART MY NAME IS JEANINE NICHOLSON
AND I AM THE CHIEF OF THE
PARENTS THE FIRE DEPARTMENT-
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ALL AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME- I WAS SWORN
IN BY MAYOR LONDON BREED OF
SHEEP THE PART IN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND ON DAY ONE A TOP
PRIORITY FOR ME WAS TO IDENTIFY
AND ACQUIRE. AT LEAST SEVEN AND
A HALF ACRES TO BUILD A FIRE
TRAINING FACILITY AND WITH
DETERMINATION AND TEAMWORK WE
FOUND ONE TWO THREE SIX CAROL
AVENUE. NOW BILL TWENTY SIX
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SALMON SO TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PURCHASE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW FIRE
TRAINING FACILITY. REPLACING OUR
CURRENT FACILITY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KING SAID THAT WILL NOT
BE AVAILABLE TO US BEYOND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. SEPARATISTS THE
VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED THE
PUBLIC SAFETY BOND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO FUND THIS PROJECT. AND
WITH OUR OTHER- TREASURE ISLAND
TRAINING FACILITY SLATED FOR
DEMOLITION WE ARE IN DIRE NEED
OF A NEW TRAINING FACILITY. ARE
PUTTING IT SIMPLY MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. IF
MY FIREFIGHTERS PARAMEDICS AND
EMTS CANNOT TRAIN YOU CANNOT
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL LIFESAVING
SERVICES. TO THOSE YOU'RE SWORN
TO SERVE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VALUABLE TIME. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
AND MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA
SHAW FOR MAYOR LONDON BREED OF
SAN FRANCISCO SHE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSUME RETAIN FOR CARING
THIS BILL TO ALLOW US TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR FIRE FACILITY.
AND WE AS WELL WANT TO THANK
MADAM CHAIR AND MR VICE CHAIR
YOUR RESPECTIVE CONSULTANTS GAVE
US GREAT FEEDBACK ON THE BILL.
AND OF COURSE THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS ALSO GREAT GIVEN
US GREAT FEEDBACK AND MEMORY
WOULD ASK YOU TO VOTE AYE ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. I DO WE HAVE
ANY OF WITNESSES FROM THE PUBLIC
AND THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. SEE NON
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR. SUPPORT EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL JUST NAME ORGANIZATION ONLY. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BEN CHAIRED KNOWING TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY
THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YOUR LATER NEXT I'M SORRY
I'VE FORGOTTEN QUESTIONS ANY
QUESTIONS I. OKAY SEE NONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD I THINK I THINK
THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL OF BILL
FOR OUR FIRE DEPARTMENT
PARTICULAR BUT THIS IS A
TRAINING FACILITY FOR MANY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
NOT GONNA DOES BENEFIT US BUT
MANY FIRE DEPARTMENTS FROM ALL
AROUND. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO
RESPECTFULLY I STRIVE VOTE FOR
AB TWENTY SIX OH SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER TEAM THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
PROMOTION FROM MR FLORES
SECONDED BY MR WOULD SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CHIU RIVAS
I RIVAS BY FLORA. FLORA I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN ACRES. MATHIS
MATHIS I MCCARTY MARTUCCI
ROBERT RIVAS SEYARTO STONE WOOD
WOOD HI. OKAY THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL PLACE AN ON CALL
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE NEXT WE HAVE- MISTER
WARD. DO YOU WANT TO START WITH
AB SIXTEEN FORTY S. PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE THANK YOU ARE NOT
AWARE MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS NOTED ME COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AB SIXTEEN FORTY WHICH
IS JOINT AUTHORED BY SOMEONE
MEMBERS BENNETT MULLIN AND QUIRK
REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH TO DEVELOP AND PUBLISH
GUIDELINES REGARDING HOW
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES ME ESTABLISH
REGIONAL CLIMATE NETWORKS. EACH
REGIONAL CLIMATE NETWORK BEING
AGING ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF REGIONAL
ADAPTATION AND MITIGATION PLANS
FACILITATING THE EXCHANGE OF
BEST PRACTICES AMONG LOCAL
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS
CONDUCTING ACTIVITIES TO SUPPORT
ONGOING COORDINATION AND
CAPACITY BUILDING MANAGING
EDUCATIONAL ACTIVITIES AND
APPLYING FOR ADMINISTERING
GRANTS. CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE GREAT IMPACTS
ON CALIFORNIA OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL DECADES COMMUNITIES ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING ITS EFFECTS
SUCH AS INCREASING SEA LEVEL
RISE COASTAL DID DECORATION
EXTREME DROUGHT EXTREME HEAT
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS FLOODING
AND WILDFIRES AB SIXTEEN FORTY
WILL PROVIDE A MECHANISM FOR THE
STATE TO PROVIDE EFFICIENCIES
AND ECONOMIES OF SCALE FOR
REGIONS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE. I HAVE MAX THE BILL IS
ANY WITH THE CLIMATE ACTION
CAMPAIGN ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
THE- THANK YOU. OPERATOR Q.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR OUR
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT. PARDON
ME MADAM CHAIR THAT THE NAME OF
THAT PERSON MAXI POLICY NEED.
YOUR LINE SHOULD BE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN YOU GIVE ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT COULD NOT BE LISTENING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CLIMATE
ACTION CAMPAIGN AND THE SENATE
AGREEMENT THE ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE- OPR TO
DISABILITY THE CREATION OF
REGIONAL CLIMATE NETWORK AND
STANDARDS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF REGIONAL
CLIMATE ACTION PLANS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO SPEARHEADED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SCIENCE BASED
AND DATA DRIVEN ROADMAP TO
DECARBONISING THE REGION'S
ECONOMY CALLED THE REGIONAL THE
CARBONIZATION FRAMEWORK FOR RT
AT. 8% RECOMMENDATION FOR
SECTORS SUCH AS ENERGY LAND USE
TRANSPORTATION WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE NATION'S BIRTH WELL QUITE
AFRICAN WRITER REGION FORTY
APARTMENT. HOWEVER A RECENT
POLICY ANALYSIS OF THE RDF
REVEALED THAT NO CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN IN THE REGION IS ON TRACK
TO REACH EMISSION REDUCTION
COMMITMENTS. AND SOCIAL EQUITY
COMPONENTS ARE LIMITED.
INCONSISTENT AND ON SPECIFIC.
IT'S THAT IT IS NOT A- WORK.
WORKING I LOVE AND WE NEED TO.
COORDINATOR RISK. TO ADDRESS THE
ENTIRE OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN A
WAY SAFEGUARDS THE LIVELIHOOD OF
COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. I THINK DOES
NOT STOP AT ANY JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARY THE REPRESENTATIVE.
SHARED REGIONAL CHALLENGE AND
EPICENTRAL THREAT THAT REQUIRES
REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO CROSS
SECTOR COLLABORATION TO PROMOTE
RESILIENCE DEVELOPMENT. FOR
HUMAN AND ECOLOGICAL HEALTH AS
WELL AS ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
INCONSISTENCIES IN THE WAY THE
POLICY ACTION WILL ONLY INCREASE
THE RISK OF WORSENING CLIMATE
DRIVEN IMPACT TOWARDS SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC SYSTEM. YESTERDAY THE
UN SECRETARY GENERAL WARNED THAT
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN PARIS
AGREEMENT GOAL OF LIMITING
GLOBAL TEMPERATURE RISE TO TWO
POINT SEVEN DEGREES FAHRENHEIT
ABOUT THE INDUSTRIAL LEVEL. IS.
AND I QUOTE UNLIKE. OUR THAT ARE
BASED AFFORD TO WAIT ANY TO WIN
LIKE. THAT AND SUPPORTS THE- OF
REACH OUT OF. AND MITIGATION
PLAN. FOR THIS REASON WE ARE TO
THAT BODY. EIGHTY SIX POINT
FORTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I AM YOUR LEADER. THANK YOU-
NEXT WERE READY FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ARE THERE
ANY AND THE HEARING ROOM. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HAVING A MILE AND A
HALF THE MID PENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR Q.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO AB
SIXTEEN FORTY. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SERVICE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
BY FIFTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LEE A
FORMER CAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE IN A
PUBLIC MUST AMENDED PETITION
ALTHOUGH R. BENNETT WERE
DISCONNECTED YOU VERY SMALL
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL WHICH I
BELIEVE WERE ADDRESSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THEN IT TODAY AND
I. INDICATE THAT HE- TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE WILL LOOK
FOR TO REBUILDING OPPOSITION
WHAT IF YOU DON'T THAT AND
PRINT. AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE AUTHOR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US. FIND. FORTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
POSTION NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF REPORT
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS IN THE COURT. LINE.
EIGHTY FIVE. INSURE MEMBERS OF
THE CENTERS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. FINE.
EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS INJURED COACH- ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
FORTY THANK YOU. AND A FINAL
CALL LADIES AND GENTLEMAN FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT PARDON ME WE DO HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON. BETTER GO
TO LINE NINETY EIGHT. THIS IS
SANTIAGO TRIPS WITH CALIFORNIANS
I'M INCLUDED IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU I'M NEXT TO OPEN IT UP
FOR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM MISS FRIEDMAN
SECOND BY MISTER WOULD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DERIVE A- THANK YOU- THE MOTION.
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. JERRY THIS
HI. I TO REVERSE AYE FLORA.
FLOOR NO FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA. MATHIS WHAT UPLOADING
MCCARTY RIGHT MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SEYARTO STONE
WOOD WOOD I. THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL PLACE IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU SO YOUR NEXT BILL IS
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWO TWO TWO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD HANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN AB
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
ADOPT A TRADITIONAL ECOLOGICAL
KNOWLEDGE OR TDK POLICY AFTER
CONDUCTING A LISTENING TOUR AND
RECEIVING INPUT FROM NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHAT ONE THIRTY K.
POLICIES ADOPTED A MUST BE
INCORPORATED INTO CONSERVATION
AND MANAGEMENT OF LANDS OWNED OR
MANAGED BY DEPARTMENTS BOARDS
CONSERVANCIES ARE COMMISSIONS
UNDER THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY DEVELOPING THIS POLICY
THE THAT'S RESOURCES AGENCY
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO ALSO
IMPLEMENT GUIDANCE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CONTRACT WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES LASTLY IN
CRAFTING THE POLICY STEPS WILL
BE TAKEN UP HONORING UPHOLD THE
SOVEREIGNTY RESPECTED
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY RIGHTS OF
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES AND
RESPECT TO THE COMMITTEES TIME I
WILL TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER WARD- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- ANY
TESTIMONY IN THE HEARING ROOM.
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB.
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE. YES I'VE
GOT MY OWN BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. FIND
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
. YES- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF PUBLIC STREET
ON BEHALF OF THE JOHN TO INCLUDE
THE TRIED A WE ARE WORKING WITH-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD ON THE SALE
THE CHECKPOINT URGED HIM TO
PLEASE MAKE SURE THE TRAVEL
CONSULTATION PROCESS IS TO OUT
THE PROCESS NOT JUST FROM
LISTENING TO OVER. AND THEY'LL
BE A COUPLE OF OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT WE MAY ASK. THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. CASEY NINE OF WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MANAGER RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVA. THANK YOU SO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JERRY LEWIS HI JERRY THIS HI
FLORA FLORA I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
SEYARTO STONE WOULD. WOOD I. THE
BILL HAS SEVEN BOATS WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN SO MEMBERS CAN ADD ON
THANK YOU MISTER WORD. WE HAVE A
FEW BILLS LEFT I BELIEVE WE'RE
READY TO HEAR FROM MISS
FRIEDMAN. FOR ITEM TO AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL I A M. SAID ACCEPTING
THE SUGGESTION AMENDMENT ON PAGE
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
CORRECTS A DRAFTING ERROR.
GLOBALLY THE E. COMMERCE
INDUSTRY USES ALMOST THREE
BILLION POUNDS OF PLASTIC
PACKAGING- AND THAT WAS JUST IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND OF THAT E.
COMMERCE BUSINESSES IN THE U. S.
GENERATED SIX HUNDRED MILLION
POUNDS OF PLASTIC PACKAGING
WASTE AND THAT IS PURE WASTE
THAT'S NOT USED BY ANYBODY FOR
ANY REASON EXCEPT TO RECEIVE THE
SHIPMENT OF BY CONSUMER GOODS.
LAST YEAR CONSUMERS SPENT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS ONLINE WITH U. S.
MERCHANTS BUT WAS UP 44% OVER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH
ALMOST A THIRD OF THE WORLD'S
POPULATION NOW BUYING ONLINE THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC PACKAGING
GENERATED IS ESTIMATED TO MORE
THAN DOUBLE BY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THE STAGGERING GROWTH
EXCEEDED TO OUTLAST THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS CREATING AN
UNSUSTAINABLE WAVE OF SINGLE USE
PACKAGES AND PACKAGING. ALMOST
ALL OF WHICH IS HEADED DIRECTLY
TO A LANDFILL OR TO INCINERATION
OR OUT INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
WHERE IT POLLUTES OUR WATER WAYS
AND PRODUCED POLLUTES OUR LANDS
AL LIKE MANY OF YOU I ALSO BUY
THINGS ONLINE SOMETIMES AND I AM
ALWAYS APPALLED AT THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC PACKAGING THAT COMES
WITH SOME PRODUCTS. NOW SOME
RETAIL SERVER RETAILERS HAVE
GOTTEN A LOT BETTER AND I'VE
SEEN MANY OF THEM STARTING TO
ELIMINATE PLASTIC PACKAGING
ALTOGETHER BUT MANY DON'T SEEM
TO HAVE GOTTEN THE MEMO AND I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE HAD THE
EXPERIENCE OF BUYING SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT FRAGILE NOT BREAKABLE
BUT YET HAS COME WITH THE WAVES
OF PLASTIC. FILM WHICH IS NOT
JUST NOT RECYCLABLE BY MY CITY
BUT WHICH CONSTANTLY CLOGS UP
THEIR MACHINERY. SO THIS LEADS
TO OVERFLOWING TRASH BINS WHICH
IS TAKEN TO LANDFILLS AND MANY
OF YOU LIKE ME COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PAYING FOR THAT ARE NOT JUST
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT THE
RATE PAYERS EVEN IF YOU DO NOT
ORDER ANYTHING ONLINE AT ALL.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PAYING MORE
FOR YOUR TRASH BECAUSE OF ALL
THE PEOPLE IN YOUR COMMUNITY
THAT ARE BECAUSE OF ALL OF THAT
NON RECYCLABLE MATERIAL. FILLING
UP YOUR LANDFILL CLOSING YOUR
LANDFILL BEING HAULED WITH
DIESEL GARBAGE TRUCKS FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY. FOR NOTHING NOW WE
KNOW THAT IT'S FOR NOTHING AND
WE KNOW WE CAN DO BETTER BECAUSE
THERE ARE PERFECTLY GOOD
ALTERNATIVES TO SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING ALREADY
EXISTING ALREADY BEING
IMPLEMENTED HERE AND ELSEWHERE.
IN FACT INNOVATIVE PACKAGING
START UPS LIKE LIME LOOP AND
MUSHROOM PACKAGING ARE BASED. OR
ACTIVE RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IS HOME GROWN INDUSTRIES. AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX WILL REDUCE
THE UNNECESSARY AND UNACCEPTABLE
AMOUNT OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC USE
AN E. COMMERCE MARKETPLACE. IT
WILL SPUR THIS INDUSTRY IT WILL
SPUR THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT IT WILL ALSO STOP
PENALIZING THE GOOD ACTORS. AND
MAKING THEM BEAR THE BRUNT OF
THE BAD ACTORS IT'S GONNA PUT
EVERYONE ON A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD SO THAT ALL OF. THE ALL
THESE COMPANIES HAVE TO ACT MORE
RESPONSIBLY SPECIFICALLY AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX WILL REQUIRE A
SHIFT TO NON PLASTIC PLASTIC
PACKAGING THAT IS RECYCLABLE.
COMPOSTABLE OR REUSABLE AN
ACCEPTABLE IN CURBSIDE BINS. AND
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON EGGS UNDER
EXISTING REQUIREMENT THAT
ESTABLISHES THE- THAT PROVIDES
CARRY OUT AND DURABLE PLASTIC
BAGS PROVIDE A COLLECTION BIN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF COLLECTING
AND RECYCLING THOSE BAGS. AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX WILL REDUCE
THE MANY HARMFUL IMPACTS OF
UNNECESSARY SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PACKAGING BY PHASING OUT THE USE
OF MOST SINGLE USE PLASTIC FILMS
AND EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE
E-COMMERCE PACKAGING FOR ONLINE
RETAIL PURCHASES. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON ARE
ACTUALLY TRIGGER PACIFIC POLICY
AND COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER WITH
OCEANIA AND CHEN M. SHRIMP THE
STATE DIRECTOR OF CAL **** AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION. I WOULD REQUEST
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN- WE'RE READY FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OPERATOR Q.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IT WAS
HERE WHAT MAKES. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ACTUALLY LIKE
A TRIGGER AND I AM THE PACIFIC
POLICY AND COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER FOR THE OCEAN
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION OCEANA
ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OCEAN IS
PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TO REDUCE THE HARMFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PACKAGING
USED FOR SHIPMENT SENT DIRECTLY
TO CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS FROM
ONLINE RETAIL PURCHASES. OR
E-COMMERCE THE PUBLIC SUPPORT
EFFORTS LIKE EIGHTY TWENTY
TWENTY SIX YOU PUBLIC POLLING
RELEASED LAST MONTH FINDS THAT
73% VOTER SUPPORT POLICIES THAT
REDUCE THE USE OF PLASTIC
PACKAGING FROM ONLINE SHOPPING
AND A SURVEY CONDUCTED LAST
SUMMER REVEALED THAT 71% OF THE
AMAZON CUSTOMERS IN THE U. S.
WOULD USE PLASTIC FREE ALTERNATE
PACKAGING OFFERED THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT PRACTICAL ALTERNATIVES
TO SINGLE USE PLASTIC FILM AND
POLYSTYRENE PACKAGING ARE
AVAILABLE. IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
AMAZON INDIA ANNOUNCED THEY HAD
ACHIEVED A 1100% SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION AWAY FROM SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING LESS THAN A
YEAR AFTER THEIR DECLARATION TO
ACT ACCORDING TO NEW RECENT NEWS
ACCOUNTS AMAZON PLANS TO
ELIMINATE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PACKAGING IN GERMANY. ONE OF THE
COMPANY'S LARGEST MARKET.
COMMERCE PRIOR AND CURRENT
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS IT SINGLE
PLASTICS. DEMONSTRATES WHAT IS
POSSIBLE IN PLASTIC REDUCTION IS
A PRIORITY. ADDITIONALLY THERE
ARE U. S. MANUFACTURERS TO
PRODUCE ALTERNATIVES TO PLASTIC
CUSHIONING AND VOID FILL THAT
PROTECTED DURING SHIPMENT AND
THOSE ALTERNATIVES CAN AND
SHOULD BE USED MORE WIDELY.
CALIFORNIA MUSTELIDAE AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX COMES AS SALES IN THE
E. COMMERCE MARKETPLACE HAVE
SKYROCKETED. CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE COUNTRY IN ONLINE SHOPPING.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
ESTABLISH REQUIREMENTS THAT
ENSURE PACKAGES SENT IN AND INTO
THE STATE ARE PACKAGED AS THE
SIMPLY. AND RESPONSIBLY AS
POSSIBLE. AS A NEW MOTHER AND
THE CALIFORNIANS I FEEL STRONGLY
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TACKLE THIS
PRESSING ISSUE. WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR
LEAVING I THANK YOU A FAMILY
MEMBER STONE FOR CO AUTHORING AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. WE URGE AND I
ABOUT THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JAN EXTREM AND I AM THE STATE
DIRECTOR FOR CALPERS. WERE A
CONSUMER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WITH THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS ACROSS
THE STATE AND STUDENT CHAPTERS
AT THE UC. AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX
ALONG WITH THE SHANNON
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. WRITTEN
LEGISLATION WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE GLOBAL PLASTICS CRISIS BY
PHASING OUT THE UNNECESSARY AND
UNACCEPTABLE AMOUNT OF SINGLE
USE PLASTIC. USED TO SHIP ONLINE
PURCHASES AND INTO CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT TWO DUMP
TRUCKS WORTH OF PLASTIC AND UP
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT EVERY MINUTE.
BOTH CLASSIC DOES NOT GO AWAY
INSTEAD IT BREAKS UP INO
SMALLER PIECES. THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCOVERED IN EVERY CORNER OF
THE GLOBE. READ GOOD IN THE
OCEAN AND HARMING WILDLIFE.
MICROPLASTICS AND EVEN FOUND
INSIDE OUR OWN FOOD AND
BEVERAGES POTENTIALLY EXPOSING
AT THE HAZARDOUS COMPOUNDS AND
ADDITIVES. BUT THE PACKAGING
ADDED TO ONLINE PURCHASES DURING
SHIPMENT INCLUDING CLASSIC
MAILING ENVELOPES- PILLOWS
BUBBLE WRAP AND EXPANDED
POLYSTYRENE ARE A SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE CRISIS. ALL
OF THE PLASTIC PACKAGING THE
DISCARDED IMMEDIATELY AFTER
PACKAGES OPENED AND IS EITHER
REUSED OR RECYCLED. DYSPLASTIC
INSTEAD BECOME PLAN FILLED
BURNED OR ENTERED OUR
ENVIRONMENT WORKING PROCESS OF
THE PUTTING FOR GENERATIONS.
ACTUALLY WITH THE GROWTH OF
ONLINE SHOPPING WE KNOW
CONSUMERS WANT ALTERNATIVE
PACKAGING THAT DOESN'T POLLUTE
OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OR COFFEE RESOURCES CLEAN
UP. AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX IN
PORTLAND OREGON BELT AIMED AT
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMATIC WASTE
STREAMS AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
FOR CO AUTHORING AND HER DRIVER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE UP TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- THAT WILL BE
TESTIFYING. ON THE PHONE OVER
THE PHONE. OF FIRST IS ADAM
REGULARLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- ARE YOU
HERE IN PERSON OKAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY STATING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
DOES NOT DISAGREE THAT SINGLE
USE PLASTIC PACKAGING OR-
PACKAGED IN GENERAL THAT REACHES
THE ENVIRONMENT IS A POLLUTION
THAT. NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
CALCHAMBER AND ITS MEMBER
COMPANIES- CANDOLI WORK VERY
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE
AND RECYCLE OUR PRODUCTS- IN OUR
PACKAGING I THINK THE QUESTION
THAT WE REALLY FACE TODAY IS
WHETHER BANNING PACKAGING THAT
SERVES A CRITICAL FUNCTION FOR
SHIPPING TRULY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF GOODS THROUGH THE-
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AS AS THE
AUTHORS INDICATED. IS A GROWING
SECTOR OF OUR ECONOMY SO WE
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT- BUT
CANDIDLY IF WE SIMPLY JUST BAN
THIS PACKAGING THERE ARE
UNINTENDED ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES AND CERTAINLY
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT. AND IT
IS WHY CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. REALLY LOOK AT THE
ISSUE OF. SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PACKAGING AS HOW DO WE ACHIEVE A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT CREATES AND MARKETS UP PUTS
THE FINANCIAL OBLIGATION ON THE
PRODUCERS TO PAY FOR A MORE
ROBUST RECYCLING PROGRAM WHICH-
FOR DECADES CALIFORNIA EXPORTED
ITS- ITS MATERIALS ABROAD AND
NOW WE NEED TO DEVELOP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE MANAGE OUR OWN-
MATERIALS. HOW DO WE CREATE
THOSE AND MARKETS AND STORES
REDUCE SUPERFLUOUS PACKAGING SO
WE DON'T DISAGREE THAT THERE IS
EXCESS PACKAGING THAT CAN BE
REDUCED WE ALL AGREE IT IN
INCENTIVIZING AND CREATING
FINANCIAL MECHANISMS TO PENALIZE
IF YOU DO NOT. BECOME MORE
EFFICIENT. AND ALL OF THESE
IDEAS HAVE BEEN PUT FORTH. IN
NOT ONLY DISCUSSIONS LAST YEAR
BUT THIS YEAR AND A BROADER
CIRCULAR ECONOMY DISCUSSION
THAT'S GOING ON CURRENTLY SO WE
FIND THAT A BAND BILL ON
PACKAGING WHICH- NO DISRESPECT
THE AUTHOR BUT THERE ARE NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR A LOT OF THE
PACKAGING FOR SOME OF THESE
SECTORS WHICH ARE NOT EXEMPTED
ON THIS BILL. AND SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES IF YOUR TELEVISION
YOUR REFRIGERATORS YOUR COMPUTER
MONITORS ALL THE WHICH RELIES ON
EPS TO COME FROM SOUTHEAST ASIA
IN THE CALIFORNIA MARKET PLACE
BREAKS OR IS RETURNED BY
CUSTOMER THERE ARE MASSIVE GHG
EMISSION. IMPACTS FOR SENDING
THESE PRODUCTS BACK TO THEIR
HOUSE ORIGIN- THERE IS MASSIVE
ENVIRONMENT IMPACTS TO RE MAKING
THESE PRODUCTS THERE'S MASSIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS THE
LANDFILL IN THE ACTUAL PRODUCT
AND TO PUT IN PERSPECTIVE EPS IS
ZERO POINT 5% OF THE CALIFORNIA
WASTE STREAM SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BANNING. EPS WE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP IT
IN CONTEXT TO HOW BIG THE WASTE
STREAM IS AND WHAT PRODUCTS- THE
PROTECTING FROM DAMAGE BREAKAGE
ETCETERA AND SO WE COMMIT TO
WORKING ON A CIRCULAR ECONOMY
WITH THE PROPOSAL THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER AND BUSINESS.
COMMUNITIES BUT FORD IS THE
FIRST IN THE NATION THAT
ACTUALLY EXCEEDS ALL OTHER
CIRCULAR ECONOMY PROPOSALS OUT
THERE WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE THAT BUT WE MUST
OPPOSE- ARBITRARY BAN ON
MATERIALS WITH. CANDIDLY DATES
THAT WE DON'T SEE A REALISTIC OR
GROUNDED IN ANY SORT OF- I GUESS
REALITY OR I WOULD SAY THE
TECHNICAL FEASIBILITY SO- WITH
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE MORE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE TESTIFYING. OVER THE
PHONE WALTER ACORN FROM THE
CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR MISTER- ALCORN SORRY.
YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
JERRY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK
YOU MEASURE GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS WALTER ALCORN ON WHAT
THE CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION I REPRESENT
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS OF
CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY PRODUCTS
LIKE TELEVISIONS AND MONITORS.
ARTISTRY WE ONLY USE PACKAGING
TO GET PRODUCTS BASICALLY FROM
THE FACTORY TO CONSUMERS HOME
AND- HOPEFULLY UNDAMAGED AND WE
DO USE PACKAGING MATERIALS LIKE
EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE ALSO KNOWN
AS THE T. P. S. AND THESE ARE
CRITICAL TO ABSORBING THE
DESTRUCTIVE VIBRATION AND SHOCKS
THAT ARE NORMALLY ASSOCIATED
WITH TRANSPORT- AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NO
VIABLE ALTERNATIVES. THE EPS
INSIGHT SO OUR MANUFACTURERS
ALSO IN A SIMILAR VEIN USED FILM
TO PROTECT ITS PLACE CREAM
STIRRING SHIPMENT AND IT WOULD
ALSO BE BANNED THE BILL. SO THE
PACKAGING MATERIALS ARE IMPACTED
THE HOME AND THEY'RE NOT FOUND
IMMEASURABLE AMOUNT ANYWHERE IN
THE OUT OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENT- SO
INCREASED BREAKAGE RATES FOR
TELEVISIONS AND MONITORS AND
OTHER LARGER COMPLEX PRODUCTS
WOULD CREATE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS THAT FAR OUTWEIGH ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ASSOCIATED
WITH PRIMARY PACKAGING NOT JUST
IN TERMS OF MATERIALS OF MASS
BUT ALSO AS WITH MENTIONED
EARLIER AT THE GREENHOUSE GAS
IMPACTS. ASSOCIATED WITH
SHIPPING EMBEDDED ENERGY BODY
ENERGY ASSOCIATED WITH REDUNDANT
PRODUCTION OF NOTE ALSO THAT NO
JURISDICTION ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD EXPAND THESE CRITICAL
PACKAGING MATERIALS FOR THIS
PURPOSE ANYWAY SO I DO WANT TO
BANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
UNDERSTAFFED FOR WORKING WITH US
TO TRY TO TRY TO FIND AN
APPROACH THATAVOIDS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES LIKE THIS- BUT AT
THIS POINT WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION. OTHER ISSUES TALK
NOT BEEN RESULT IN WE CANNOT
AGREE TO THE TIME TRAINS
OUTLINED IN THE BILL HOWEVER WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DIALOGUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. VERY MUCH THAT MEASURE. THEY
YOU I'M NEXT HEAR. OF A WITH A
SUPPORT- ON- PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL WILL START
WITH THE HEARING ROOM. GOOD
AFTERNOON JERRY VISIT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IT I'M
JENNIFER FEARING. AND I AM HERE-
IN SUPPORT OF A TWENTY TWO SIX
ON OF CLIENTS THE MONTEREY BAY
A- THE OCEAN CONSERVE. CENTER
FOR SAFETY AND MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND WAS ALSO AT TO
CONVEY THE SUPPORT OF INTO CAL.
GREEN TEA INDIVISIBLE ALSO
PASSAGE THE CLIMATE CENTER AND
BAN S. U. P. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWENTY
SIX I'M JUST A REMINDER PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
NIKITA KARATE BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT STE. LINE. FIFTY SEVEN.
MICHAEL GERRY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIANS TO PROVIDE
DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT. LINE.
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON IF IS
JIM LINDBERG- OF THE FRIENDS TO
ON ACCOUNT IN TWO REPORT. FINE.
FIFTY HI GOOD AFTERNOON NAME CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES LET US. OKAY MY
NAME IS JESSICA CRAVEN I AM IN A
LOT MEMBER THE OFFICE COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF ENVIRONMENT CAUCUS THE
CALIFORNIA OF PARTY I'M- IN OUT
INTO THIS. AND BEEN DELUXE
COLLECT STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
. FIND THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VALERIE
SENTRY HADN'T ABOUT VOLUNTEER
WITH THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTIONS AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
FOR. LINE THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT LEAST BUYING A
MEMBER OF THE AND COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT. PINE NINETY
EIGHT. THIS IS SCIENCE WITH
CALIFORNIA MOMENTO BOATERS
CALLING SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
BUYING THE EIGHTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE SILENT SILENT
PARTNER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE ONE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DON KEPT KEY WITH MCCUE
CAPTION ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
AIR CONDITIONING HEATING AND
REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE ALSO AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. WINE. SIXTY ONE.
HELLO THIS MY ELAINE WITH THE
RETAILER SUCH AND WE HONOR
OPPOSED TO THE MUSLIM PETITION
THANK YOU. BLIND FIFTY. GET OUT
MEMBER CLUBS CAL MANY AND IS SO
- PUT THAT THANK YOU. LYING
SIXTY. WALTER RIDER WITH THE EPA
S. INDUSTRY ALLIANCE OPPOSED.
LINE WIDE. AFTERNOON THIS IS
ERIN WILLIAMS YEAR CALIFORNIA
AND- LINE. ONE OH EIGHT. THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS BECAUSE GORDON
WELCOME BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL IMPORT THANK YOU
. BLIND ONE THOSE SIX. GOOD.
AFTERNOON A MAN CHAIR MEMBERS
JIM SHOW.
WITH A COUPLE CHAPTERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
BEIN. THIRTY AFTERNOON CHIANG
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAMED.
ALEXANDRIA CHÁVEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF TELL.
THE MEDICAL QUESTION. AND A
FINAL ALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE NINETY TWO.
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE. FORTY SIX.
CHARMERS LUCENTIS WITH MILLER
SAYS BUT IT'S AN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE TOY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE.
NINETY TWO. H. Y. NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURA ROSENBERGER PLEASE
SUPPORT AB TWO ZERO TWO SIX I
HATE PLASTIC THAT TYPE. OF
PLASTIC AND I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
. WHY ONE HAD. HI THIS IS
ALREADY HAND ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
INDICATE SUPPORT AND SAVE OUR
SHORES THE SENATE FOR OCEANIC
AWARENESS RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
THE FIVE GYRES INSTITUTE HEAL
THE BAY RIDGE TOYOTA CHU MATCH
FOUNDATION THERE AWAITS YOU AT A
PLASTIC OCEAN INTERNATIONAL AND
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RECYCLING ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALLEN WOULD HOUSE HERE
ON BEHALF OF CALPERS UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STUDENT
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. THERE IS
NO ONE THERE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YEAH CAN I HAVE A
MOTION FOR MISTER WOULD SECONDED
BY MISTER MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SURE- JUST A FEW
THINGS FIRST OF ALL. THIS BILL
IS NOT MEANT TO BE A STATEMENT
THIS BILL IS NOT MEANT TO RAISE
AWARENESS THIS BILLS TO MEANT TO
BE SOMETHING THAT'S ACTUALLY
WORKABLE AND DOABLE. AND WILL
SET THE STANDARD FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY TO FOLLOW WE KNOW WE
HAVE A PROBLEM INDUSTRY HAS HAD
A LONG TIME TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
SOME COMPANIES HAVE A GOOD
ACTORS AND REALLY DEMONSTRATED
THAT THIS IS POSSIBLE. EVEN
ELECTRONICS COMPANIES LIKE
SAMSUNG IS BEEN ABANDONING
POLYSTYRENE AND PLASTIC THE SHIP
A LINE OF THEIR TELEVISION SETS
THEIR BIG DELICATE TELEVISION
SETS AND- THEN CUSTOM MADE
CORRUGATED CARDBOARD. BEFORE I
CAME IN THE LEGISLATURE I WAS AN
E. RETAILER A VERY SMALL BABY
RETAILER BUT ONE NONETHELESS AND
I SHIFTED GLASS I SHOULD VERY
FRAGILE OUR CLASS NOT JUST
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES BUT
AROUND THE WORLD. YES I USE
PLASTIC A LOT OF TIMES BUT THERE
ARE MANY TIMES WHEN I USE OTHER
MATERIALS LIKE CLOTH AND
CARDBOARD WHEN IT WAS AVAILABLE
AND YOU KNOW WHAT. THOSE PIECES
DID JUST FINE PART OF THIS BILL
IS ALSO TO SPUR THOSE
ALTERNATIVES AND BRING THEM TO
NOT JUST LARGE INDUSTRY WHICH
NOW IS BEING THEM BUT TO THE
STORES STAPLES SO THAT READ
SMALL RETAILERS LIKE ME CAN
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF IT. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH INDUSTRY
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
MANUFACTURERS FOR SHIPPING SOME
OF THE MOST DELICATE ITEMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHICH BY THE
WAY REPRESENT A VERY SMALL.
NUMBER OF THE SHIPPERS THAT ARE
OUT THERE MOST OF THEM ARE
SHIPPING GOODS THAT WE KNOW CAN
SURVIVE BEING SHIPPED WITHOUT
PLASTIC. SO WE HAVE EXTENDED BY
A YEAR THE TIME TABLE FOR THOSE
MOST DELICATE ITEMS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IN CONVERSATION
WITH THEM BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
WORK FOR THEM AS WELL WITH THAT
I REQUEST WE REQUEST AND I.
CONTINUE THIS TEN WITHOUT THANK
YOU. YOU'RE FREE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. ON THE ISSUE
AREA- YOU HAVE LED THE WAY- WITH
THIS BILL- AND I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND- HELP
YOU IN ANY WAY THAT I CAN. WOULD
BE BETTER VERY VERY HONORED TO
HAVE YOU IN THANKS AGAIN FOR
YOUR HELP AND HELP YOUR
COMMITTEE. THANKS SO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DISH. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. RIVAS HI
JERRY THIS AYE FLORA. FLORA NO
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY. MERCY
MURATSUCHI I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SAY ARE TO KNOW
SEYARTO NO STONE. STONE I WOULD
WOOD I. THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES-
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR AN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
OKAY WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND
DO VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE NEXT
AUTHOR. HEY WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND MOTION BY MISTER
WOULD SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CHAIR RIVAS
HI JERRY THIS AYE FLORA FLORA I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I SAY
ARE TOO HIGH C. R. TO AYE STONE
. STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. OKAY
WE'RE MISSING TO BOTH'S WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR THOSE
MEMBERS TO ADD ON WE HAVE THREE
BILLS LEFT TO AUTHORS- I DON'T
SEE ANY OF THE- OKAY SO MR
SANTIAGO. YEAH WE'RE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM FOR A LOT OF THE
BILLS YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD. WHAT SHOULD WE
DO SANTIAGO. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DO. TO SEE.
OKAY WE'RE READY FOR YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
START WHEN YOU'RE READY THE BILL
. WITH THE CHAIR PROPRIETY BRIEF
. I'M SURE WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION. SO IT'S UP TO YOU WHAT
THE MOTION AND A SECOND THANK
YOU MANAGER- ONE EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THINK-
YOU IN THE COMMITTEE FOR HARD
WORK THAT HELPING US TO MAKE
THIS A BETTER BILL AND AS
AMENDED AB. TWENTY FORTY EIGHT
WOULD HELP CREATE AN ACCESSIBLE
PUBLIC DATABASE- THAT WOULD YOU
TELL FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN WASTE RECYCLING HAULERS
ANY PUBLIC AGENCY- WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THIS INFORMATION BE AT
THE FINGERTIPS OF ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A LOOK
AND FEEL. AND AT THE COMMITTEES
GESTURE I WILL BE BRIEF AND
INTRODUCED THE FIRST WITNESS A
MANAGER. PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER SHANE GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL.
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND HOW TO SAY THAT THE
THAT WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL. VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
MEMBERS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY. THANK
YOU I'M WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES REGISTERED TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. SO GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP. TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ARE THERE ANY OKAY SEE AN NON
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY FORTY
EIGHT.
OPERATOR ARE YOU THERE. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH- CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. AND
AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. C.
NONE. OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I THINK THE MANAGER RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR MISTER MATHIS SECOND
FROM MR FLORIDA THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. JERRY THIS HI
JERRY THIS HI FLORA. FLORA HI
FRIEDMAN. EGGMAN AYE GARCIA
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS ICR
TOO HIGH C. R. TO AYE STONE.
STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL
HAS NINE VOTES WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT
HERE THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S. I
WE'RE GONNA GET WHILE WE WAIT
FOR THE LAST AWFUL SHE'S HERE
OKAY THE CASE LAST AUTHOR OF THE
DAY. THIS GARCIA HAS TWO BILLS.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM THREE AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY A- LITTLE. OKAY
ITEM A THREE SEVENTEEN FORTY
NINE I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE
WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO IDENTIFY IN
EACH COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
BLUEPRINT UPDATE MEASURES TO
REDUCE CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS
AND TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS WILL
ALSO REQUIRE A DISTRICTS IN
THEIR ANNUAL REPORTS TO INCLUDE
RESULTS FROM COMMUNITY EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS IN THE
ACTIONS TAKEN TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THE BILL ALSO INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY VERY CRANE A
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY THAT HAS
APPROVED PERMITS OF THE MISSION.
TO MAKE THAT PERMIT AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE AND ALSO GIVE UP TO
ONE ADDITIONAL YEAR TO ADOPT
COMMUNITY EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAMS WITH CONSENT OF THE
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT WITH ME I HAVE REBEKAH
GONZALEZ DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OKAY OPERATOR WE'RE
READY FOR OUR FIRST WITNESS
REBECA GONZALEZ TESTIFYING OVER
THE PHONE. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ AND I'M THE
DIRECTOROF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
AND POLITICAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY NINE
THOUSAND POSTAL WORKERS WITH A
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO IDENTIFY AND EACH
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
BLUEPRINT UPDATE. MEASURES TO
REDUCE CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS
AND TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WE WORK
WITH MANY COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE
IN POVERTY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE SEVERELY
OVERBURDENED BY CUMULATIVE
EMISSIONS FROM MANY SOURCES
INCLUDING TRUCKS AND CARS ON THE
FREEWAY SUPPORT WAREHOUSES RAIL
YARDS VARIOUS INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES. AND OTHER
SIGNIFICANT SORTS THAT EACH
COMMUNITY SEPARATE FROM HIGHER
RATES OF ASTHMA CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE LOW BIRTH RATE AND MANY
OTHER SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS
INCREASING OVER A FEW THINGS TO
ADDRESS CURRENT CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT AND HE'S ALREADY
OVER BURKE NEIGHBORHOOD IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. IN ADDITION THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE OFTEN OCCUPIED
BY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO ARE
THE TARGETS AND DECADES OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN OUR COMMUNITY BEING
LOCATED IN AREAS IMPACTED BY
HIGH ANDERSON. WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THE
SPELLING FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK. FOR YOUR I. ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M WE DON'T HAVE
WAY. REGISTER TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION- SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE. ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEE NON OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. REALLY GO TO LINE
FORTY FOUR. MADAM CHAIR NUMBER
IS THE KEY TO KARATE WITH ENERGY
FEE IN SUPPORT. HI LINE WHAT-
NINE. MEDICARE MEMBERS BALBIR
ARE REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
MAKE SHOWING MR SPEECH AND WE
HAVE WHAT WHAT I THINK IS A
CLARIFYING CONCERNS. WE BELIEVE
HAVING CAR WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
IDENTIFY CONTROL MEASURES AT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE BOTTOMS UP
APPROACH OF THE S. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN PROGRAMS WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
IDENTIFIES THE CHANGE TO UPDATE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THAT POINT OF
CLARITY THANK YOU. FIND. ONE OH
FOUR. THANK YOU AND CHAIR AND
MEMBER THIS IS BROUGHT BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO. I'M SURE NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HEY OF
. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT ONE
I THINK THE CHAIR AND STUFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD WILL
CONTINUE TO STAY IN TOUCH-
CLOSELY A NATIVE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. FOR THE
MOTION. THANK YOU YEAH WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. CAN WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR MISTER MURATSUCHI
SECOND BY MISTER WOULD THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I TERRY VEST HI
FLORA FLORA NO FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
. MATHIS NO MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SEYARTO. NO C. R.
TO KNOW STONE STONE I WOULD.
WOOD I. THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN- FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND
THEN OUR FINAL BILL FOR TODAY-
ITEM FOR AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN CORRECT SUFFICIENCY
IN WASTE MANAGEMENT LAW THAT HAS
CAUSED HARM. IN A REPORT
COMMITTEES OVER THREE DECADES.
THE INTEGRATED WITH MANAGEMENT
ACT. UP FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE MANDATE TO DIRT THAT
JURISDICTION'S MONTH EVER AT
LEAST 50% OTHER WASTE AWAY FROM
LANDFILLS. AND INTO SOURCE
REDUCTION RECYCLING REUSE AND
COMPOSTING ACTIVITIES HOWEVER
THE ACT DOES PERMIT UP 210% OF
THE WASTE. I TO BE SENT TO
MUNICIPAL SOLID WASTE
INCINERATOR TOWARDS OBLIGATION
TO THE READ AT LEAST 50% OTHER
WASTE AWAY FROM LANDFILLS
OTHERWISE ON A SAID THAT VERSION
CREDIT. MANY JURISDICTIONS ALSO
REQUIRED BY CONTRACT THAT THESE
WITH HAULERS- LEASE WITH US HAVE
A RATE HIGHER THAN FIFTY
PERCENT. IT'S PAST THE
LEGISLATURE UPDATE STATEWIDE
POLICY ON MUNICIPAL INCINERATORS
TO BETTER ADVANCE EQUITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY AND WASTE
MANAGEMENT LOSS. MAKING CLEAR
THAT BURNING TRASH IS IN A
RECYCLING ONCE AND FOR ALL.
MUNICIPAL INCINERATORS ARE A
REMINDER OF HIGH RENT
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM CAN BECOME
NORMALIZED IN POLICY F. A
NEUTRAL. POLICY SOLUTION WHEN
THE STORIES ALWAYS MORE
COMPLICATED. SENATE LEADERS AMID
NUMEROUS TYPES OF HAZARDOUS AIR
POLLUTANTS SUCH AS AMMONIA AND
LET HIM PRODUCE THOUSANDS OF
TOXIC. ASH LACED WITH HEAVY
METAL AS WELL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NAY VOTE. YEAH I HAVE
WITH ME THOMAS HOME WITH THE
VALLEY IMPROVEMENT PROJECT AND
WITH NEHEMIAH WITH EAST YARD
COMMUNITIES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO- TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
K. OPERATOR WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
. THOMAS HELM AND WHITNEY AMAYA. BILL OKAY HEARING THIS YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON- JERRY LEFT THE
VICE CHAIR FLOOR MEMBERS OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS THOMAS HELM I GREW UP IN
CURRENTLY RESIDE IN STANISLAUS
COUNTY ON THE CO FOUNDER AND
PROJECT DIRECTOR OF VALIANT
PROVEN PROJECT A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
SOCIAL ND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. SINCE OUR FOUNDING TEN
YEARS AGO WE HAVE BEEN RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WESTEM FLOSS AS ONE OF THE TWO
REMAINING TRASH INCINERATORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ADVOCATING FOR THE COUNTY INNER
CITY TO WORK TOWARD MORE
SUSTAINABLE WAYS PRACTICES THAT
DON'T RELY ON INCINERATION THIS
IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
REPORT COMMISSIONED BY THE
CALIFORNIA WASTE MANAGEMENT
BOARD STATED THAT RURAL LOW
INCOME CATHOLIC COMMUNITIES WITH
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR LESS.
WHO WORK IN FARMING AND RANCHING
WOULD BE THE LEAST LIKELY TO
OPPOSE AN INCINERATOR BUILT IN
THEIR AREA ONE YEAR LATER
CONSTRUCTION OF COVANTA
STANISLAUS INCINERATOR BEGAN IN
WESTON FONG IN THE AREA
HISTORICALLY HOME TO FARMWORKERS
WITH A POPULATION THAT IS NEARLY
80% PEOPLE OF COLOR MAINLY
LATINOS. NOT ONLY IS THE
INCINERATOR ONE OF THE LARGEST
STATIONARY SOURCES OF AIR
POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE GASES
IN STANISLAUS COUNTY IT ALSO
INCENTIVIZES THE CREATION OF
MORE TRASH AND DISINCENTIVE EYES
IS MORE SUSTAINABLE LOCAL WASTE
PRACTICES FOR EXAMPLE MODESTO
HAS NO RESIDENTIAL CURBSIDE
RECYCLING SERVICE DESPITE HAVING
ONE OF THE FIRST ONES IN THE
COUNTRY BEFORE THE INCINERATOR
WAS BUILT. MOST RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL THAT IS THROWN AWAY
MODESTO IS BURNED AT THE
INCINERATOR IN ADDITION OVER A
HUNDRED CITIES SEND WASTE TO BE
BURNED AT THE INCINERATOR EVERY
YEAR OUR COMMUNITY SHOULD NOT BE
A DUMPING GROUND FOR THE STATE
INCINERATION IS NOT RECYCLING
AND IT IS NOT THE VERSION AND IT
IS HINDERING CALIFORNIA'S VISION
OF BEING A MODEL ZERO EMISSIONS
AND ZERO WAIT STATE OF THE
FUTURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THE COMMITTEE VOTE AYE ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THE MILITARY MEMBERS OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS CLICKING ON MY END
AND IS THERE A WAY COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER EASTER COMMUNITY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE A
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT THAT
WORKS WITH THE ADVOCATE FROM
LONG BEACH TO EAST LOS ANGELES
AND BOYLE HEIGHTS REPUBLICAN
MEMBER MENTAL RACISM IN
ADDRESSING INDUSTRIAL POLLUTION
IN OUR COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO
MAKE THEM THE THINKER AND
HEALTHIER THANK GOODNESS. I AM
ALSO A RESIDENT OF WEST PALM
BEACH ONE OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
BUT IT'S CLOSE TO ONE OF THE
LAST TWO REMAINING WITH A PHOTO
ID WITH THE READER IN
CALIFORNIA. AS IS THE CASE FOR
ABOUT 80% OF THE INCINERATOR TO
HAVE BEEN CITED IN CONSTRUCTIVE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BOTH OF THE
INCINERATORS IN CALIFORNIA THE
SOUTHEAST RESOURCE RECOVERY
FACILITY AND COME BACK THE
SENATE BUKHARI ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE PREDOMINANTLY PEOPLE OF
COLOR THAT ARE LOW INCOME AND
ARE OVER. BURDENED BY MULTIPLE
SOURCES OF POLLUTION. YOUR
INDUSTRYHAS TRIED TO REBRAND.
AS WE THE ENERGY TO MAKE THEM.
LOOK IN VERY IN THE- HOWEVER DO
INCINERATOR ARE HARD. OUTDATED
AND IF. THANK AND FROM MINIMAL
AMOUNT ENERGY RETURN. IT DOES
NOT IN EVERY MAKE. THAT THEIR
INCOME THE PALACE LAW SHOULD
ELLA. FOR A CRAP. WHEN THEY BOTH
HAVE INCLUDING OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THE ENVIRONMENT PROBLEM
THIRTY FIVE YEAR. THESE HAVE HAD
CONTINUE TO SUFFER THE IMAGE OF
THESE. SECOND TO THE AIR IN OUR
REGION. THERE ARE LOCAL
INCINERATOR HAS REPEATEDLY
EXCEEDED THE EMISSIONS ALLOWED
BY PERMIT. BUT HAS AVOIDED
ACCOUNTABILITY BY CLEANING START
UP SHUT DOWN AND LOG FUNCTION
EXEMPTION. MEANWHILE OUR
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO FEEL THE
IMPACT FOR HEALTH. IN ADDITION
TO AIR POLLUTION BUSINESS
INNOVATORS OF THE POLITICAL AND
WATER THIS IS A TOPIC AT THAT IS
LEFT OVER CALVET SEKALI HAVE
NOTED SEVERAL TIMES THAT THEY'RE
PREGNANT. THE PUCK THE CASH THAT
WILL COMMITTEES TO LANDFILL IN
THE FORM OF CLOCK. AND BUILD UP
ON NEARBY ROADS. THEY HAVE EVEN
NOTICED DIFFICULTY READING
EXPECTED ONLY COME OUT ONCE A
MONTH BUT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
HERE EVERY DAY AND WE DESERVE
BETTER. ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE
ARE EXISTING THEIR WAY
STRATEGIES THAT PRIORITIZE FOR
PRODUCTION RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING. FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO BE SUPPORTABLE I. EIGHTY
EIGHTY FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE DON'T HAVE. A
WITNESS. A REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE READY FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. TO AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WILL START WITH. THE
HEARING ROOM. GET AFTERNOON THAT
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM IN
SUPPORT. YOU OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE OH SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO LEAH
LEVIN WITH THE BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE A TWEENER WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S- GOALS
WITH THIS BILL TO HAVEN'T AND
INCINERATION OF TRASH. BUT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. BY REMOVING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TRANSFORMATION
THE BILL COULD ALSO BE
INTERPRETED. TO EXCLUDE NON
INCINERATION NON COMBUSTION
ALTERNATIVES. THAT THE STATE
REALLY NEEDS TO MEET THE 75%
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION
REQUIREMENTS SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. THE STATE SHORTLY KIND OF
CLINTON LOST HEART. WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF. THANK YOU. JUST
A REMINDER WE'RE TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
ONE ONE THIRTEEN. HI IT'S JOHN
KENNEDY WITH R. C. R. C. AGAIN-
WE'RE GRAPPLING OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AND IF I COULD INDULGE
YOU FOR JUST A COUPLE MOMENTS TO
PROVIDE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THE
PERSON THANK YOU WE'RE ONLY
TAKING OF NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. BUYING
FORTY ONE HAVE ANY. SUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE MEMBERS NICKEL
KOREAN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AS A CO SPONSOR
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SIXTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT GERMAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE- LEGISLATION A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. LINE FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU
CANNOT INSURE NUMBERS NICKY
DOCHERTY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY
EIGHT. BARBARA DEVON THIS WITH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION IS TRYING TO PARK
THANK YOU. FIND. THIRTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIN
HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. LINE. ONE FIFTEEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE ELEVEN CLEAN SEAS LOBBYING
COALITION ORGANIZATIONS AND
THEIR MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. PINE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT- IN BETWEEN HER
POSITION AT THIS POINT. LINE.
NINETY EIGHT. THIS IS SANTIAGO
TO CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LINE THIRTY FOUR. HM NUMBER I AM
A SINGLE PARENT ON BEHALF OF MR
CONGRESSIONAL RECORD OF EIGHTY
EIGHT POINT. THANK YOUNG. LINE
ONE TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY
SCHAEFER WITH SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
SIX. ONE SIXTY SIX OR ONE IS NOW
OPEN. FINAL COLLEAGUES IN GERMAN
FOR WHOEVER WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BOTH TO GO TO LINE SIXTY SECS. HELLO THERE MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THEM WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AGAIN CALLING AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. WHY NINETY TWO. THIS IS
LAURA HAIDER WHO PRESENTS
AGAINST FRACKING I SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE LEAD LEAD TO EARLY
DEMENTIA. THANKS. FIRST NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER WHAT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- MISTER SEA I'M FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE TRANSFORMATION
FACILITIES PIECES OF THE BILL
HOWEVER I AM CONCERNED ABOUT A
PROVISION IN SECTION THREE OF
THE BILL. THAT WOULD GIVE CAO
RECYCLE SIGNIFICANT NEW
AUTHORITY OVER JURISDICTIONS
THEY NEED TO DEVELOP A NEW WASTE
FACILITY INCLUDING A NEW
LANDFILL. I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
ARE WASTED DIVERSION WASTE AND
REDUCTIONDIVERSION GOALS I SAT
ON THE- ON- WASTE MANAGEMENT
AGENCY FOR SEVERAL YEARS WHEN I
WAS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER- BUT
WILDFIRES ARE TAKING A TOLL ON
ON. ON THESE- FACILITIES BECAUSE
WE CAN'T RECYCLE THAT AND FOR
EACH HOUSE. THERE'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF WASTE THAT HAS TO BE
DISPOSED OF. AND NOW WE'RE
POTENTIALLY GOING TO MAKE IT
HARDER FOR JURISDICTIONS TO SITE
AND IT'S ALREADY EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT A NEW A NEW LANDFILL
SOMEWHERE SO I I'LL SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY BUT I HOPE YOU WORK
ON NARROWING THAT. THAT PIECE OF
THE LANGUAGE IN IN. IN IN IN A
KNOWLEDGE MENT OF SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ALREADY FACE
AN INSIDE IN A LANDFILL. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP- IN IN THE SPACE.
BOTH AND- THE WASTE MANAGEMENT
BUT ALSO WITH THE WILDFIRES OUT
THERE. IN IN SOME INSPECTORATE
DOES MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT- I
THINK MICHAEL AND IF THERE'S A
WAY TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL IN THAT
ENSURE WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL
OTHER. MEANS OF REDUCING WASTE
BEFORE WE ARE PERMITTED A NEW
LANDFILL AND IF THERE'S A BETTER
WAY TO DO THAT. I'M DEFINITELY
OPEN TO THAT I DO THINK WE COULD
ACHIEVE BOTH AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
WILL FOLLOW UP. CAN I JUST POINT
OUT WHEN THERE'S A WHEN THERE'S
A WILDFIRE IN THEIR HOUSES
INVOLVED- THE WASTE HAULERS
COULD THE HOLLERS COME IN AND
THEY THEY'VE THEY'VE LITERALLY
WRAP IT UP IT'S LIKE A BIG
BURRITO FOR LACK OF A- BATES
PLASTIC AROUND IT. THAT'S TOXIC
IT'S BIG IT'S NOT RECYCLABLE
THERE'S NO WAY IN THE WORLD YOU
CAN RECYCLE THAT NOBODY EVEN
REALLY KNOWS WHAT'S IN THERE.
AND THAT IS FILLING UP LANDFILLS
ALL OVER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND- AND OTHER PROBABLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. SO WE HAVE
TO COME TO GRIPS WITH THAT
REALITY. BUT I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT. HOW DIFFICULT IT ALREADY
IS TO CITE- LANDFILL- AND NOW.
GIVING ANOTHER AT AN AGENCY MORE
AUTHORITY. TO POTENTIALLY MAKE
THAT MORE DIFFICULT AT SOME
POINT. YOU KNOW WE CAN'T JUST
LEAVE THIS OUT THERE- AND THAT'S
THAT'S HUGE PROBLEM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. AND I APPRECIATE IT
I'VE ACTUALLY VISITED ONE OF THE
LANDFILLS THAT'S ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA IT'S TAKING. US SOME
OF THIS. DEBRIS OUT THERE. AS
WELL AND SO I DO BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A WAY- WHEN
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO LOOK AT.
SOURCE REDUCTION AND WHEN AN
APPROPRIATE TO CARVE THAT OUT ON
AND THIS IS A WILL DEFINITELY
FOLLOW UP ON THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. CASEIN NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE TWEETERS AND RC
RC IN IN THEIR OPPOSITION- AS
WELL I THINK THAT THERE'S- SOME
AMENDMENTS COMING THAT CAN START
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
OF NOT ALL OF THEM AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
MOTION FOR MISTER MAYOR SU CHI.
ALL SECOND. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER MOORE SU CHI SECONDED
BY I THINK MR STONE THANK YOU-
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL JERRY THIS HI
RIVAS HI FLORA. FLORA NO
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NO
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SEYARTO NOPE
SEYARTO NO STONE. STONE I WOULD
. WOOD I. THE BILL HAS. EIGHT
EIGHT VOTES SO EIGHTY THREE THE
BILL IS OUT OF WE HAVE SEVERAL
BILLS EITHER THAT ARE ON CALL OR
NEED MEMBERS TO ADD ON SO ALMOST
ALL OF THEM THAT WERE HEARD
TODAY. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND WE
NEED MOTIONS FOR SOME OF THEM SO
THE FIRST BILL IS AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN CAN HAVE A MOTION. CAN WE
HAVE A MTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY THE MOTION- LET ME SEE
WHAT IS THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
YOUR DISH. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO REVERSE HI TERRY
THIS HI FLORA. FLORA I FRIEDMAN
. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS I MCCARTY. HI
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
SEE ARE TWO ZERO TWO AYE STONE
STONE I WOULD. WOOD I WAS
ELEVEN- THE BILL HAS ELEVEN
VOTES BILLS OUT- REPORTER RIGHT
YEAH OKAY I'M NEXT AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO DO DISH.
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I. EIGHT TWO PEOPLE THE
BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES THE BILL IS
OUT. THE NEXT ONE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY
. MCCARTY I. EIGHT EIGHT VOTES
BILLS OUT. NEXT IS AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY WE ARE THE- OKAY SORRY-
ITEM FIVE AB. TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. SECOND IS MOTION BY
MISTER WOULD SECOND BY MISS
GARCIA THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
JERRY THIS HI RIVAS HI FLORA
FLORA I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
SEYARTO NONVOTING. ZERO NOT
LOADING STONE STONE I WOULD.
WOOD I. FEEL HAS TEN VOTES THAT
PULLS OUT. OKAY ITEM SIX I'M AB. NINETEEN FIFTY SIX I BELIEVE
WE NEED A MOTION WE DO. THE MOVE
SECOND K. MOTION BY MISS GARCIA
SECOND BY MR SAY YOUR TOTAL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL RIVAS HI RIVAS TO
REVERSE HI FLORA. FLORA I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SEE ARE TOO HIGH
C. R. TO AYE STONE. STONE NO
WOULD. WOOD I THE BILL HAS TEN
VOTES FOR BILLS OUT ITEM TEN
RIGHT IF ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX WE NEED A MOTION.
THE SECOND MOTION BY MISS GARCIA
SECOND BY MISTER MAYOR SU CHI
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HEALTH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JERRY THIS HI JERRY THIS AYE
FLORA FLORA I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY I'M
RESEARCHING MURATSUCHI I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I SEE
ARE TWO NONVOTING HERE TO NOT
VOTING STONE. STONE I WOULD.
WOOD I. TEN THE BILL HAS TEN
VOTES THOSE OUT- ITEM ELEVEN AB. TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT WE
NEED WE NEED A MOTION. OKAY WE
WILL MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INSURANCE. JERRY THIS HI JERRY
THIS AYE FLORA FLORA I FRIEDMAN
. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I SEE ARE TOO HIGH
C. R. TO AYE STONE. STONE I
WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL HAS
ELEVEN BOTH SETS OUT THANK YOU.
ITEM THIRTEEN YES AB. SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA.
BURKE NOVEL IS NOT LOADING
MURATSUCHI NOT BY NOT VOTING.
AND STE DON'T STONE NO AND
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS HI.
EIGHT THE BILL HAS A BOTH SETS
OUT. IDM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
FORTY EIGHT. THE MOTIONS IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I WAS ELEVEN
BILLS BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES THAT
BILLS OUT ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS UTILITIES AND ENERGY GARCIA
. GARCIA I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS AYE
STONE. STONE I. EIGHT THE BILL
HAS A BOTH SETS OUT ITEM SIXTEEN
AB. TWENTY SIX OH SEVEN. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GARCIA. R. C. I.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SAY ARE TOO HIGH
C. R. TO AYE STONE AYE STONE AYE
. THE BILL HAS ELEVEN BOTH SETS
OUT ITEM SEVENTEEN AB SIXTEEN
FORTY. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS GARCIA
. GARCIA I MURATSUCHI PURSUE G.
I. C. R. TO. NUMBERING NOT
VOTING STONE BY STONE I. BILL
HAS EIGHT BOTH SETS OUT AND OUR
FINAL BILL ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHRIS GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SEE ARE
TOO HIGH C. A. R. TO AYE STONE.
DON'T I WE HAVE THE CONTENT HOW
MANY PEOPLE TO WHAT THE LEFT OF
THAT BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES IT'S
OUT AND WE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
YEAH I THINK I BELIEVE SOME A
FEW MEMBERS HAVE TO ADD ON TO
THE CONSECUTIVE WILL BE DONE
GARCIA GARCIA I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
ELEVEN VOTES- AND IT'S OUT WERE
READY TO ADJOURN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. RIGHT NOW. YEAH.